What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. What matters most to you? Is it unforgettable adventures? Connections with lifelong friends?
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更棒的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口，在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池，就能订购到这样一块大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单免运费优惠。服务费、除外条款和适用条款。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。什么对您最重要？是难忘的冒险吗？与终身好友的联系吗？
Peaceful moments of reflection? Feelings of joy and freedom you can't wait to experience again and again? Or is it the vehicles that help you make all those special moments possible? Whatever your answer is, Toyota is here to bring you closer to the things that matter to you. Because they matter to us too. Toyota. For what matters most. Welcome to the second drink of Conflict Resolution.
宁静的沉思时刻吗？那些让您迫不及待想要一次又一次体验的快乐和自由的感觉吗？又或者是那些帮助您实现所有这些特殊时刻的交通工具？无论您的答案是什么，丰田都在这里，让您更接近那些对您重要的事情。因为它们对我们来说也同样重要。丰田。为了最重要的事。欢迎来到《冲突解决》的第二杯饮品。
We had a bunch of fantastic background catches in this episode. You guys are so on top of it. And I have some candy bag alts to share. I will start with a background catch. In this breakdown, we read out a list of Jim's pranks and we talk about how one of our favorites is when Jim says he puts nickels in Dwight's phone receiver to make it really heavy and then he takes them all out and then Dwight hits himself in the head with the phone. Well, we got some mail with a really fun background catch. A few of you pointed this
这一集中我们有很多精彩的背景捕捉。你们真是太敏锐了。我还有一些糖果袋的备选台词要分享。我先从一个背景捕捉开始。在这个解析中，我们读了一份吉姆恶作剧的清单，我们谈到了我们最喜欢的恶作剧之一，就是吉姆说他把镍币放进德怀特的电话听筒里让它变得很重，然后他又把它们全部拿出来，结果德怀特用电话砸到了自己的头。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件，里面有一个非常有趣的背景捕捉。你们中的几个人指出了这一点，
out, so we wanted to share. If you go all the way back to the pilot episode, you see Dwight unlock his desk drawer and inside is the phone headset. I know, that's so cool. And you all wrote in and said, that is probably because of the time that he hit himself in the head with it. So now he started locking it up so that Jim can't mess with him. I love it.
所以我们想分享一下。如果你回到试播集，你会看到德怀特打开他的抽屉，里面放着电话听筒。我知道，这太酷了。你们所有人都写信来说，这很可能是因为他用它砸到自己头的那次。所以现在他开始把它锁起来，这样吉姆就不能捉弄他了。我喜欢这个。
Also, do you guys remember how Pam changes her mind about inviting Angela to her wedding to Roy? Pam says she didn't have Angela's zip code and she gives her a handwritten invitation. Do you remember that? Yes. And then Angela has this talking head in the kitchen and she kind of judges the save the date.
另外，你们还记得帕姆是如何改变主意，决定邀请安吉拉参加她和罗伊的婚礼的吗？帕姆说她没有安吉拉的邮政编码，然后她给了她一张手写的请柬。你还记得吗？记得。然后安吉拉在厨房里有一个谈话头（talking head），她对那张“预留日期”请柬有点评头论足。
She's a little snarky. Well, there were some candy bag alts for that talking head. We didn't share them on our first breakdown. They're super snarky and fun, and I wanna read them to you. All right. Angela has the save the date in her hand, looks to camera and says, hand delivered.
她有点刻薄。好吧，那个谈话头有一些糖果袋备选台词。我们在第一次解析时没有分享它们。它们超级刻薄又有趣，我想读给你们听。好的。安吉拉手里拿着“预留日期”请柬，看着镜头说，亲手送达。
Gloating a bit, Phyllis got a mass mailing. Oh, so she felt superior that she got hand delivered. The next talking head says, Angela, in parentheses, the martyr. Obviously it means a lot to Pam, so I guess I'll find a way to be there. Next one. Oh, I'll be there, but she may have to wait
有点幸灾乐祸，菲利斯收到的是群发邮件。哦，所以她觉得因为是亲手送达而高人一等。下一个谈话头说，安吉拉，括号里写着，殉道者。显然这对帕姆意义重大，所以我猜我会想办法去参加的。下一个。哦，我会去的，但她可能得等
a while for the RSVP. Okay. Last one. She's been at that computer with all the address labels in it for five years and she couldn't find my zip code? She'll make one heck of a wife, that's for sure. Wow, a real variety. Well, we got a lot of mail about that save the date
一会儿才能收到回复。好的。最后一个。她在那台装有所有地址标签的电脑前坐了五年，却找不到我的邮政编码？她肯定会成为一个了不起的妻子，那是肯定的。哇，真是多种多样。好吧，我们收到了很多关于那张“预留日期”请柬的邮件，
because Angela, when you hold it up, it says location TBD. But in the episode Dwight's speech, which is four episodes before conflict resolution, Pam says that the wedding is at the VA because Roy has a connection there. Remember, there's a scene in the kitchen and Kelly asked Pam about it. Kelly says, why'd you pick the VA for the reception? And Pam says, Roy has a connection. It's nicer than you think. And then Ryan says, are you inviting Jim? And Pam says, of course, he's one of my closest friends. Oh, right. And then Kelly and Ryan have a look.
因为安吉拉，当你举起它时，上面写着地点待定。但在《德怀特的演讲》那一集中，也就是《冲突解决》的前四集，帕姆说婚礼是在退伍军人事务部（VA）举行的，因为罗伊在那里有关系。记得吗，厨房里有一个场景，凯利问帕姆这件事。凯利说，你为什么选VA作为招待会地点？帕姆说，罗伊有关系。它比你想象的要好。然后瑞安说，你要邀请吉姆吗？帕姆说，当然，他是我最亲密的朋友之一。哦，对。然后凯利和瑞安对视了一眼。
Yes. So here is the question. We know that Pam didn't even want to invite Angela, right? Because she couldn't quote unquote, find her zip code. Right. And then when she does give her a save the date, she puts TBD? Is Pam ever going to really tell Angela where this wedding is? Maybe not.
是的。所以问题来了。我们知道帕姆甚至不想邀请安吉拉，对吧？因为她“无法”找到她的邮政编码。对。然后当她真的给她一张“预留日期”请柬时，她写了待定？帕姆真的会告诉安吉拉婚礼在哪里举行吗？也许不会。
I mean, Pam did say, you know, it's my wedding and I don't want to invite someone who's called me a hussy. So maybe she just gives her the... Maybe she's hoping Angela will forget about it. Doesn't follow up. But I thought that was a good catch. That is a really good catch, especially since she's already said where the wedding's gonna be. Yes, four weeks ago. We also found out what happened to the baby jazz poster, which is at the heart of this
我的意思是，帕姆确实说过，你知道，这是我的婚礼，我不想邀请一个叫我荡妇的人。所以也许她只是给她……也许她希望安吉拉会忘记这件事。不去跟进。但我认为这是一个很好的发现。那确实是一个非常好的发现，尤其是因为她已经说过婚礼要在哪里举行了。是的，四周前。我们还发现了那个“婴儿爵士”海报的下落，它处于这个
conflict and conflict resolution. So you know, the original from the set was auctioned off at that big NBC auction where they sold everything. Wow. It sold for $355. But if you really love it, you guys, there's a ton of different versions of it online. You can find it in so many places. Dazzle, Redbubble, Etsy, it's out there.
《冲突解决》的核心。所以你知道，片场原来的那张海报在NBC那场大型拍卖会上被拍卖了，他们卖掉了一切。哇。它以355美元的价格售出。但如果你真的很喜欢它，伙计们，网上有成吨的不同版本。你可以在很多地方找到它。Dazzle、Redbubble、Etsy，到处都有。
I would kind of love to walk into someone's house and just see that baby jazz poster framed above their couch. So like framed really nice with like matting and like the whole thing. Exactly. Finally, before we go, I just really loved this note from Ambus Hunter IV, who said, I am an alternate dispute resolution mediator with the Department of the Navy, and we use clips from this episode to display ways not to handle mediation during our certification classes.
我真的很想走进某人的家里，看到那张婴儿爵士海报装裱在他们的沙发上方。就像装裱得很好，有衬纸，还有整套东西。完全正确。最后，在我们结束之前，我真的很喜欢Ambus Hunter IV的这条留言，他说，我是海军部的一名替代性争议解决调解员，我们在认证课程中使用了这一集的片段来展示不该如何处理调解。
Oh my gosh. The Department of the Navy uses office clips. Well, I'm glad we could be of service. Yes. And now, here is our breakdown of conflict resolution. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
天哪。海军部使用《办公室》的片段。好吧，我很高兴我们能帮上忙。是的。现在，这是我们对《冲突解决》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello everyone and welcome to Conflict Resolution. I'm talking to you from my closet today. I know we're both in our closets today.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。大家好，欢迎来到《冲突解决》。今天我是在我的衣橱里和你们说话。我知道我们今天都在各自的衣橱里。
What is happening? We're both talking to each other from our closets and Sam and Cody are watching. I'm looking at Cody's cat. Love it. Sam's dog is somewhere there. This is where we're at now folks. Angela, your shirts are very well folded. Are those Josh's shirts? No baby girl. Baby girl. Are we doing that again this week? We are. Here's the thing, I've started every morning by talking to my family in Texas and Louisiana and then it just is kind of with me for the whole day. This is my closet. My own closet. I share it with no one. It is a personal life victory. Oh my gosh. I only get one side of a closet. We have one closet and I get one side and Lee gets the other. Although to be honest, I think I have encroached on about a third
这是怎么回事？我们都在衣橱里互相交谈，萨姆和科迪在看着。我正在看科迪的猫。太喜欢了。萨姆的狗就在那儿的某个地方。伙计们，这就是我们现在的处境。安吉拉，你的衬衫叠得真整齐。那是乔什的衬衫吗？不，宝贝。宝贝。我们这周又要那样了吗？是的。事情是这样的，我每天早上都从和德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州的家人通话开始，然后它就一直伴随着我一整天。这是我的衣橱。我自己的衣橱。我不和任何人分享。这是一项个人生活胜利。天哪。我只能用衣橱的一侧。我们只有一个衣橱，我用一侧，李用另一侧。虽然老实说，我想我已经侵占了他那一侧大约三分之一的空间。
of his side. Well, Josh has his own closet, but one wall of it is my shoes. This is the riveting content that people tuned in for. I know, I know, listen, but just bear with me one second. Here is a perk of not growing since like your junior year of high school. Maybe a little wider in some places, but I've had the same shoe size since I was... Angela, you're describing most adults. I mean most adults hit their peak height somewhere around their junior, senior year of high school. It's not like it's not like other people are continuing to grow four or five inches in
好吧，乔什有他自己的衣橱，但其中一面墙是我的鞋子。这就是人们收听的引人入胜的内容。我知道，我知道，听着，但请忍受我一秒钟。这是从高中三年级以来就没有长高过的好处。也许在某些地方宽了一点，但我从……开始就一直穿同样的鞋码。安吉拉，你描述的是大多数成年人。我的意思是大多数成年人在高中三年级或四年级左右达到身高巅峰。并不是说其他人还在20多岁和30多岁时继续长高四五英寸。你的脚码和你高二时一样吗？当然一样。我从高中三年级开始就一直穿七码半的中号，我去上大学时就已经完全长成了。我完全长成了。哦，我拉开了连帽衫的拉链，你们听到了吗？听起来像个屁。听起来你放了个屁。什么？那不是屁！听起来像个屁。那是我的拉链！你声称你拉开了连帽衫的拉链，这很好。确实是！天哪，我明白了。所以我们在这儿。
their 20s and 30s. Do you have the same size foot is like when you were a sophomore? Of course you do. I've been a seven and a half medium since like you know junior junior year of high school I was fully grown when I went to college. I was fully grown Oh, I unzipped my hoodie could y'all hear that? It sounded like a toot. It sounded like you tooted What? It wasn't a toot! It sounded like a toot. It was my zipper! It's good that you're claiming that you unzipped your hoodie It was! Oh my gosh, I see how it is. So we're here.
今天是冲突解决日，如果你看不出来的话。这是第二季第21集，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔导演。开始！开始！这一集对我来说真的非常非常有趣，我喜欢查尔斯，我和他在这一集中有很多发挥空间，因为猜猜怎么着，安吉拉·马丁有很多冲突。我应该给个总结吗？好的。所以这一集里发生了两件主要的事情。
It's conflict resolution day if you can't tell. It's season two episode 21 written by Greg Daniels and directed by Charles McDougall. Action! Action! This was a really really fun one for me and I love Charles and he and I got to play a lot in this episode because guess what Angela Martin has a lot of conflicts. Should I give a summary? Yes. All right. So there are two main things that happened in this episode.
第一，邓德·米夫林的每个人都被发放了身份识别徽章。所以人们一个接一个地走进休息室，拍下他们的徽章照片。第二，迈克尔从托比那里拿走了那叠员工投诉，并开始试图通过强迫人们在工作中面对彼此来逐一解决它们。是的。所以我对这一集有一点小看法。所以德怀特一直在喋喋不休地说办公室的安保有多糟糕，对吧？在邓德·米夫林。是的。我们拿到了这些徽章，但之后再也没戴过。不。好吧，你知道，有一个删减片段，据说是第二天，
One, everyone at Dunder Mifflin is being issued an ID badge. So one by one, people go into the break room and have their photo taken for their badge. And then secondly, Michael takes the stack of employee complaints from Toby and starts trying to resolve them one by one by forcing people to confront one another at work. Yeah. So I have one little thing about this episode. So Dwight is like going on and on about how horrible the security is at the office, right? At Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. We get these badges, we never wear them again. No. Well, you know, there's this deleted scene where it's supposedly the next day
我们早上都走进来，我们都戴着徽章。汉克也在那个场景里。汉克一直坚持要德怀特出示他的身份证件，他假装看不懂，然后德怀特错过了电梯。所以我猜我们只在一段从未播出的标签片段里戴过一次。对。但没有，我们从来没戴过。这就像是某种“休闲星期五”之类的东西。确实是。
and we're all walking in in the morning and we all have our badges on. And Hank is in the scene. And Hank keeps insisting that Dwight show his ID badge and he pretends like he can't read it and then Dwight misses the elevator. So I guess we wore them once for a tag that never aired. Right. But no, we don't ever. It's, you know, it's sort of the casual Friday of it all. It is.
对吧？真的。是的。真的。看，珍，我为你把话题带回了休闲星期五。我很感激。我真的很感激。你要用一些快讯（fast facts）来轰炸我吗？你知道我会的。
Right? It really is. Yeah. It really is. It really, look, Jen, I brought it back to casual Friday for you. I appreciate that. I really appreciate that. Are you going to hit me with some fast facts? You know I am.
我要用快讯来轰炸你。我能要我的音效吗？快讯！是的，顺便说一下，那是来自DDB。我上周没有提到他，所以我这周想提一下。他是一位音效工程师，给我们发了那个音效。非常感谢那个音效。它确实让我感觉自己像是在参加20世纪80年代的游戏节目什么的。快讯！我喜欢！好的，快讯第一条。这一集里有一位特别客串明星。扮演身份识别徽章
I'm going to hit you with some fast facts. Can I get my sting? Fast fact! Yeah, that's from DDB by the way. I did not give him a shout out last week so I wanted to do that this week. He's a sound engineer who sent us that sting. Thank you so much for that sting. It does make me feel like I'm like in a 1980s game show or something. Fast facts! I love it! Alright, fast fact number one. We have a special guest star in this episode. Playing the ID badge
摄影师的是斯科特·阿德西特。斯科特·阿德西特！我太喜欢这家伙了。我认识他很久了。他是我的即兴表演伙伴，从即兴奥林匹克时期就开始了。我昨晚还在和他发短信。我告诉他我们正在看这一集。他有一些有趣的话要说。你想听听吗？你知道我想听。斯科特·阿德西特是一位了不起的即兴表演者、演员、喜剧演员。
photographer, it is Scott Adset. Scott Adset! I love this fella so much. I've known him a really long time. He's an improv bud of mine back from the Improv Olympic days. And I was texting with him last night. I told him we were watching this episode. And he had some fun things to say. Do you want to hear him? You know I do. Scott Atzit is an amazing improviser, performer, comedian.
你可能在《我为喜剧狂》中认识他。此外，你的孩子们认识他是因为他是大白。他是《超能陆战队》里的大白。巴达达达达达。总之，好吧，那是我的大白，斯科特。你做得好多了。所以这是他和我分享的一点幕后花絮，
You might know him from 30 Rock. Also, your children know him as Baymax. He's Baymax and Big Hero 6. Ba da da da da da da. Anyway, okay, that's my Baymax, Scott. You do it much better. So here's a little behind the scenes tidbit that he shared with me
他记得拍摄这一集时的情景。他说他记得瑞奇·热维斯这周来片场参观，每个人都兴奋不已。他说瑞奇对我们片场的制作规模以及一切与他在英国的制作相比感到高兴和惊讶。他说瑞奇非常谦逊和可爱。天哪。我不记得瑞奇在这一集期间来过。
that he remembers from filming this episode. He said he remembers that Ricky Gervais came to visit set this week and everyone was abuzz. He said that Ricky seemed delighted and surprised by the scale of the production of our set and everything compared to maybe what his production of it had been like in the UK. And he said that Ricky was just very humble and sweet. Oh my gosh. I did not remember that Ricky visited during this episode.
是的。我的意思是，他在前几季里进进出出，你知道，但斯科特记得见过他，他说他真的很好。天哪，这就像是快讯里的快讯。什么？那是双重快讯。我帮你得到了一个双重快讯吗？你做到了。你做到了。安吉拉，在这个快讯里我有一个有趣的事实。你和斯科特都出现在了电视剧《神探阿蒙》的两集中。
Yeah. I mean, he popped by in and out those first couple seasons, you know, but Scott remembered meeting him and he just said that he was just really nice. Oh my gosh, that's like a fast fact within a fast fact. What? That's a double fast fact. Did I help you get a double fast fact? You did. You did. Angela, I have a fun fact within this fast fact. Both you and Scott have appeared in two episodes of the TV show, Monk.
我出演了一集，是的，我扮演的是凶手。好吧，斯科特出演了第三季和第四季。所以你们两个加起来，涵盖了《神探阿蒙》的四季。恭喜。这就是我的有趣事实。《神探阿蒙》拍摄起来非常有趣，托尼·夏尔赫布是最棒的。我们在场景之间坐在一个小长凳上，他扔东西试图把它扔进垃圾桶。当它击中垃圾桶时，发出了一种“叮咚”的声音，我开始笑，他也开始笑。
I was in one episode, yes, and I played the murderer. Well, Scott was on seasons three and four. So between the two of you, you cover four seasons of Monk. Congratulations. That's my fun fact. Monk was so much fun to shoot, and Tony Shalhoub was the nicest. We sat on like a little bench in between scenes and he was throwing something to try to get it in the trash can. And when it hit the trash can, it made like a ping-wong and I started laughing and he started laughing.
我说，我的意思是，那声音真好笑。然后我们两个坐在那里，模仿东西掉进垃圾桶的声音，就像，我们真是书呆子，我们笑得前仰后合。我不知道。他真是太有趣了。我简直崇拜他。那个快讯真是充满了有趣和快讯。那是一个非常充实的快讯。那是一个充实的快讯。那是一个充实、有趣、双重的快讯。
And I said, I mean, that was kind of a funny noise. And then the two of us sat there and did our impressions of the noises of things going in the trash can like, we were such dorks and we cracked up. I don't know. He's just so fun. I just adored him. That fast fact was just chock full of fun and fast facts. That was a very full fast fact. It was a full fast fact. It was a full, fun, double fast fact.
极其有趣的充实快讯。天哪。快讯第二条。好的，快讯第二条是来自扎克·阿克斯的粉丝提问。他是这样写的。为什么吉姆在窗户外面做他的谈话头，而其他人的谈话头都在面向办公室办公区的窗户里面？他说在《布斯游轮》和后面的一些剧集中，有吉姆和帕姆在外面窗户前的联合谈话头，但通常帕姆或其他任何人都不坐在那个外面的窗户前。然后他注意到因为吉姆在这一集里有几个谈话头，他觉得吉姆在那里非常突出。所以我认为这是一个很棒的问题，也是一个非常明智的观察，我必须调查一下。不，那是一个很棒的发现。确实是。所以，我
Fantastically fun, full fast fact. Oh my gosh. Fast fact number two. Okay, fast fact number two is a fan question from Zach Akers. And here's what he wrote in to say. Why does Jim do his talking heads in front of the outside facing window, while everyone else's talking heads are inside of the window that faces the bullpen of the office. He says in Boo's Cruise and some later episodes there are joint Jim Pam talking heads in front of the outside window but neither Pam nor anyone else normally sits in front of that outside window. And then he noticed because Jim has several talking heads in this one he was like it's really prominent in this episode that Jim is there. So I thought that was a great question and such a wise observation I had to investigate. No that is a great catch. It really is. So I
给格雷格·丹尼尔斯发了电子邮件，我问他这是故意的吗？这是一个意外吗？他有什么要说的？他说这是我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩向格雷格建议的，从试播集就开始了。格雷格非常喜欢它。他说兰德尔的意图是，这不一定非要是吉姆，但想法是，任何在邓德·米夫林之外有未来或持有某种内在乐观情绪的角色，都会坐在通向世界的窗户前。但那些不想离开邓德·米夫林的角色，
emailed Greg Daniels and I asked him was this deliberate? Was this an accident? What does he have to say? And he said that it was something that Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer, suggested to Greg, starting with the pilot. And Greg absolutely loved it. He said Randall's intention here was that it didn't necessarily have to be only Jim, but the idea was that any character that had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin or held some sort of internal optimism would sit in front of a window leading out into the world. But characters who didn't want to leave Dunder Mifflin
或者可能处于被困境地的人，会面向办公室做他们的谈话头。哇。太深刻了。太深刻了。这真的很深刻。是的。我坐在这里绞尽脑汁想我的角色是否曾经坐在那面墙上，
or who maybe were in more of a position of being trapped would do their talking heads facing into the office. Wow. That's so deep. That's so deep. That's really deep. Yeah. I'm sitting here racking my brain to think of my character ever sat on that other wall
窗户朝外，而我能想到的是，我认为这可能是唯一的一次。我试着想还有没有别的。那是你和我做《大孕妇，小孕妇》的时候。是的，我们做了。我想这是我唯一一次坐在那里。好吧，很长一段时间，
with the window facing out behind her and the one that comes to my mind, and I think it might be the only one. I'm trying to think if there's any other one. It was when you and I did Big Pregs, Little Pregs. Yeah, we did. I think it's the only time I ever sat there. Well, for a very long time,
我只有在和吉姆在一起时才坐在那里，这真的是帕姆在办公室之外唯一可能的未来。哇，太深刻了。这不疯狂吗？但除此之外，她相当被困在她，你知道，和罗伊在一起的糟糕决定中。被困住或满足，你知道？我的意思是，我们中的一些人只是对生活中的现状感到高兴。是的。好吧，这太迷人了，我喜欢它。是的，我觉得那是一个很好的发现。所以非常感谢你，扎克，指出这一点
I only sat there if I was with Jim, which was really the only possible future for Pam outside of the office. Wow, that's so deep. Isn't that crazy? But otherwise she was rather trapped in her, you know, bad decision of being with Roy. Trapped or content, you know? I mean some of us were just happy with our lot in life. Yes. Well that is fascinating and I like it. Yeah, I thought that was a good one. So thank you so much, Zach, for pointing that out
并写信进来。现在，最后，快讯第三条，安吉拉，这是一个快讯闪回。你在做什么？怎么了？你喝醉了吗？所以这是这个快讯。这一集是在2006年5月拍摄的。所以，安吉拉，我问我们俩的问题是，闪回到2006年5月，你在做什么？好吧，我有一篇2006年5月3日的日记。这是我写的。我写道，我正在和我的猫露西一起为《猫迷》杂志拍摄照片。安吉拉·金赛。什么？现在就把前门关上。你知道我在日记里写了什么吗？不知道。在2006年5月的这一周。我和我的猫安迪一起为《人物》杂志拍了照片。我没在开玩笑，女士。女士，我们怎么会不知道我们在
and writing in. Now, finally, fast fact number three, Angela, it's a fast fact flashback. What are you doing? What is up? Are you drunk? So here is this fast fact. This episode was filmed during May 2006. And so, Angela, my question for both of us is what were you doing flashback now to May 2006 and what were you up to? Well I had a journal entry from May 3rd 2006. This is what I wrote. I wrote that I was doing a photo shoot with my cat Lucy for cat fancy magazine. Angela Kinsey. What? Shut the front door right now. Do you know what I wrote in my journal? No. For this week of May of 2006. I did a photo shoot with my cat Andy for People magazine. I'm not joking lady. Lady, how did we not know that we did
这个可爱的时期和我们的猫拍了照片？世界上发生了什么？我觉得我们当时可能知道，但我们俩分享2006年5月初的日记条目对我来说太搞笑了，我们俩都因为和猫拍照而感到非常高兴。天哪。首先，这就是为什么我们是闺蜜。好吗？这就是为什么我们的生活有非常奇怪的平行方式。那么露西在《猫迷》的封面上吗？不，露西不在封面上，因为她是救助猫。她不是纯种猫，但珍娜，
photo shoots with our cats at this cute time? What is happening in the world? I feel like we probably at the time knew, but it's hilarious to me for us to both share our journal injuries from early May 2006 and we were both so tickled that we were taking photos with our cats. Oh my gosh. First of all, this is why we're BFFs. All right? This is why our life has very strange ways that it is parallel. So was Lucy on the cover of Cat Fancy? No, Lucy was not on the cover because she was a rescue. She was not a purebred cat, but also Jenna,
《猫迷》不让猫奴上封面。所以那是只有猫在封面上。好的，但酷的是露西和我得到了，我想，我的意思是，我保存了那本杂志。我想我们得到了大约四页。所以露西和我在中间，我猜是插页。哦，你是《猫迷》杂志的插页。所以露西和我看起来棒极了。我觉得那是我拍过的最好的照片。她在拍摄过程中表现如何？好吧，是的，我应该给你一些关于露西的背景故事。露西喜欢睡觉。哦。所以露西什么也没做。露西只是躺在那里，我的意思是露西，我爱她。她，安息吧露西。她度过了美好而漫长的一生，但她真的只是喜欢休息。她是个休息者。
Cat Fancy doesn't let humans on the cover. So That's like it's only cats on the cover. Okay, but the cool thing was is that Lucy and I got like I think I mean I saved the magazine. I think we got like four pages. So Lucy and I are in the center I guess for the centerfold. Oh You are the centerfold of catancy magazine. So Lucy and I look amazing. There's some of the best pictures I feel like I have. How was she during the photo shoot? Well yeah I should probably give you some backstory about Lucy. Lucy loved to sleep. Oh. So Lucy did nothing. Lucy just laid there and I mean Lucy, I love her. She, RIP Lucy. She had a great long life, but she really just loved to lounge. She was a lounger
哦，所以在很多镜头里，我只是躺在她旁边，因为那是她最喜欢做的事情。但你呢？你和安迪的《人物》杂志拍摄是什么样的？好的。好吧，安迪也是一只救助猫。但他是一只半野猫。我也救助过，但他是一只半野猫。我发现他时，他正在密苏里州柯克斯维尔的一家垃圾桶里吃东西，我在那里上的大学。我想我得到他时他大约五六个月大。他总是有点，
Oh, so I in many shots. I'm just laying next to her because that's like her favorite thing to do But what about you? What was your people magazine shoot like with Andy? Okay. Well Andy was also a rescue But he was a semi-feral cat. I also a rescue, but he was a semi-feral cat. I had found him, he was eating out of a dumpster back in Kirksville, Missouri, where I went to college. I think he was about five or six months old when I got him. He was just always a little,
我们说他总是有点野。他爱我，他依偎着我，他非常温柔可爱，但他不喜欢家里的陌生人。所以当《人物》杂志的人过来时，他们不仅都在那里制造混乱，你知道，安迪有点像，我得离开这里。他们想在外面拍照片，他们想让我抱着他，算了吧，我的是在室内。哦，天哪，我化了全妆，穿着这件裙子，他们说，好的，我们准备好了，你能带着安迪出来吗？所以我抱着安迪，我想如果你看照片，你可以看到他和我都有一点紧张，但我笑得超级大，好像我不紧张一样。我在日记里写道，
we say he was always a little wild. He loved me and he snuggled me and he was so gentle and sweet, but he didn't love strangers in the house. And so when the People magazine guys came over, not only were they all there kind of causing a ruckus, you know, and Andy was a little bit like, I'm out of here. They wanted to do the photo shoot outside and they wanted me to hold him forget it mine was inside oh oh my gosh i'm in like full hair and makeup with this dress on they were like okay we're ready for you will you come out with andy so i'm holding andy and i think if you look in the photo you can see that he and i are both a little tense but i'm smiling super big as if i'm not tense. And I wrote in my journal,
安吉拉，我在日记里写道，他抓伤了我的肚子，因为拍摄照片时他想逃跑，我的肚子里有血淋淋的抓痕。哦，女士。我不敢相信我们俩都在2006年5月拍了猫的照片。而且我们俩都在日记里写了这件事，而且我们的经历如此截然不同。我确实记得给我妈妈打电话，我非常兴奋，因为我以前从来没有上过任何杂志，显然，在我的一生中。我说，妈妈，我要上《猫迷》了。
Angela, I wrote in my journal that he clawed my stomach and I had like, like bloody claw marks in my stomach from the photo shoot because he wanted to get away. Oh, lady. I can't believe that we both did cat photo shoots in May of 2006. And also that we both wrote about it in our journals and also that our experiences were so vastly different. I I do remember calling my mom and I was so excited because I hadn't really been in any magazines ever, obviously, in my whole life. And I was like, Mom, I'm going to be in Cat Fancy.
我妈妈说，妈妈，我要上《猫迷》了。我妈妈说，什么？我说，我和露西，妈妈？总之，这太可爱了。我喜欢那个。现在我真的很想看。我记得你做了那件事，但现在我需要看那张照片。好的，好吧，我化了很浓的妆，真的很多妆。我以一种非常奇怪、疯狂的方式笑着。在那次拍摄之后，我给我妈妈打了电话，安吉拉，
And my mom was like, mom, I'm going to be in cat fancy. And my mom was like, what? I was like, me and Lucy, mom? Anyway, that is so cute. I love that. Now I really want to see. I remember you doing that, but now I need to see the picture. OK, well, I have a ton of makeup on, just a ton of makeup. And I'm smiling in a really weird, maniacal way. And I called my mom after that photo shoot, Angela,
我妈妈太贴心了。她说，哦，我为你们俩感到骄傲。真的为你们俩感到骄傲。她说，想想你在密苏里州柯克斯维尔的那个垃圾桶里发现的那只小猫。他和你一路开车到洛杉矶，登上了《人物》杂志的页面。你给了他什么样的生活啊。
and my mom was so sweet. She was like, oh, I am just so proud of you both. Just so proud of you both. She's like, just think about that little kitten that you found in that dumpster in Kirksville, Missouri. He drove all the way to Los Angeles with you onto the pages of People magazine. What a life you've given him.
那太可爱了。那真是个妈妈时刻。天哪。我知道。好吧，就是这样。结束了。那是我的第三个快讯闪回。我喜欢它。那些真的很有趣。好的，伙计们。好吧，也许我们应该休息一下，然后回来解析这一集《冲突解决》。让我们开始吧。那些真的很有趣。好的，伙计们，也许我们应该休息一下，然后回来解析这一集《冲突解决》。
That is so adorable. That is such a mom moment. Oh my Lord. I know. Well, that's it. That's the end. That was my third Fast Fact Flashback. I like it. Those were really fun. All right, guys. Well, maybe we should take a break and then we'll come back to break down this episode of Conflict Resolution. Let's get into it. Those were really fun. Alright guys, well maybe we should take a break and then we'll come back to break down this episode of Conflict Resolution.
让我们开始吧。安吉拉·马丁，我有一张这一集的卡片，它叫“整个办公室的傲慢”。哦，我想我知道你在说哪个场景。我等不及了。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。我刚和我妈妈见过面，我一直在思考她作为成年人如何真正影响了我的生活。我非常钦佩她的一点是，当她需要时，她总是愿意寻求帮助。为自己辩护。是的。
Let's get into it. Angela Martin, I have a card for this episode and it's called The Whole Office Sass. Oh, I think I know the scene you're talking about. I can't wait. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah.
好吧，你知道，心理健康意识现在正在增长，但仍有进展要做。在最近的一项调查中，26%的美国参与者表示，由于害怕被评判，他们避免寻求心理健康支持。好吧，在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人照顾好自己的幸福，打破污名。BetterHelp完全在线。它让治疗变得负担得起
Well, you know, mental health awareness is growing now, but there's still progress to be made. 26% of Americans who participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking mental health support due to fear of judgment. Well, this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their wellbeing and break the stigma. BetterHelp is fully online. It's making therapy affordable
且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。你可以随时免费更换治疗师。有了帮助，我们都会变得更好。今天访问betterhelp.com/office ladies，首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp，H-E-Lhelp.com/office ladies。以下内容是在冰浴中录制的。啊，呜！好的，好的。当酷乐（Coors Light）足够冷时，
and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-Lhelp.com slash office ladies. The following was recorded from inside an ice plunge. Ah, woo! Okay, all right. When a core's light is cold enough,
罐子上的山脉会变成蓝色。所以下次你想喝冷拉格、冷过滤、冷包装的酷乐时，只需等到罐子上那些壮丽的山脉变成蓝色。呜，当你冻得发抖时，说得那么快很容易。我们回来了。安吉拉，你开启了这一集。
the mountains on the can turn blue. So the next time you want a cold lager, cold filter, cold package, core's light, just wait until those glorious mountains on the can turn blue. Whoo, it's easy to say that fast when you're freezing gold. And we're back. Angela, you open up this episode.
我开启的。我的意思是，我不认为这在我的角色身上经常发生，但它从我这里开始得非常快，大约在一秒钟时。我正在那台复印机上复印，然后镜头平移到你和凯文在接待处。安吉拉，你复印的时候为什么不关上复印机的盖子？我不是唯一一个注意到这一点的人，因为莫莉·内特也想知道，安吉拉。可能是因为那台复印机坏了。真的吗？那台复印机总是有问题。有一次我复印时，我不得不按住它的一侧。我想他们不想让我关上它。那会很具体。
I do. I mean, I don't think this happens very often with my character, but it starts with me very quickly at like one second in. I'm making copies on that copier and then the camera pans over to you and Kevin at reception. Angela, why didn't you close the top of the copier when you're making the copy? I'm not the only person who noticed this because Molly Nett also would like to know Angela. Probably because that copier didn't work. Really? There was always a catch to that copier. One time I made copies and I had to hold the side of it shut. I think that they didn't want me to shut it. That would have been specific.
那会是查尔斯·麦克杜格尔作为导演，他真的关注一切。所以这绝对是有原因的。要么A，如果我关上它，它就不能工作，因为那台复印机有100岁了。要么他们想要那种在复印机上扫过的光。100岁了，或者他们想要那种在复印机上扫过的光。也许他们喜欢这种效果。但这是一件经过深思熟虑的事情。我肯定这一点。好的。但这不像安吉拉·马丁的角色选择。我只在
That would have been Charles McDougall as a director, he really had his eye on everything. So there was definitely a reason to that. Either A, if I shut it, it wouldn't work, because the copier was 100 years old. Or they wanted that light that pans across the copier. 100 years old or they wanted that light that's like pans across the copier. Maybe they liked the effect. But it was a thought out thing. I'm sure of that. All right. But it wasn't like Angela Martin's like character choice. I only photocopy with a
强光照在我的脸上时复印。完全正确。所以当你打开复印机复印后，帕姆在她的办公桌前，她正在做她的婚礼策划，凯文问他的乐队是否可以在婚礼上演奏。但凯文正在做一件让我非常恼火的事情。就像任何走过来开始敲桌子或在某物上重击的人，我想折断他们的手指。这让我发疯。你不喜欢那样。我受不了。谁喜欢那样？
blinding light in my face. Exactly. So after you copy with the copier open, Pam is over at her desk and she's doing her wedding planning and Kevin asks if his band can play in the wedding. But Kevin is doing something that is such a pet peeve of mine. Like anyone that walks up and starts tapping a table or thumping on something, I want to like break their fingers. It makes me crazy. You don't like that. I can't take it. Who likes that?
谁喜欢那样？有些人就像没意识到，没意识到。就像你可以走过去，他们就像，随便。但你在我周围那样做，我就像，你有什么问题？你知道我不喜欢什么吗？吹口哨。哦，那些走来走去的人，是的，
Who likes that? Some people are like oblivious, oblivious. Like you can like walk by and be like, and they're like, whatever. But you do that around me and I'm like, what is your problem? You know what I don't love? Whistling. Oh, people who walk around just, yeah,
是的，我受不了。是的。抱歉。抱歉。吹口哨的人。好的。所以我们发现帕姆没有邀请安吉拉参加她的婚礼。这是因为她不想让任何叫她荡妇的人在那里。安吉拉，在我的谈话头背景里，我在谈论你叫我荡妇，你在厨房里吃东西。
yeah, I can't. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. Whistlers. All right. So we find out that Pam did not invite Angela to her wedding. And this is because she doesn't want anyone there who's called her a hussy. Angela, in the background of my talking head where I'm talking about you calling me a hussy, you're eating in the kitchen.
在45秒时，你看起来真的在吃东西。你饿了吗？伙计们，看看45秒，安吉拉在背景里狼吞虎咽地吃着她的食物。在那个场景里，他们让我吃百吉饼。每当我能吃那种东西时，我都非常兴奋，我就像，是的，我会吃掉整个百吉饼。给我点奶油芝士黄油。我在这儿。那是冷开场，对吧？我们回来，这一集以迈克尔的谈话头和菲利斯拍照片开始，这就是我们发现
At 45 seconds, you seem like you are really eating. Were you hungry? Guys, check it out 45 seconds Angela is scarfing down whatever her food is in the background. In the scene they let me eat a bagel. I was really excited whenever I got to eat something like that I was like yeah I'll eat that whole bagel. Give me some cream cheese butter. I'm here. That's the cold open right? We come back, the episode opens with a Michael talking head and Phyllis getting her photo taken and this is the scene where we find out that
每个人都在为他们的新身份识别徽章拍照的场景。是的，在删减片段里，如果你有这一集的DVD，这是一张特别棒的DVD。所以DVD套装里的第四张碟，第四张碟有评论。它有删减片段。它有花絮。它有我们制作的虚假公益广告。它有我们制作的奥运会宣传片。它有会计师，那个网络剧系列，它赢得了艾美奖。是的。所以它有，这是一张非常好的碟。
everyone's being photographed for their new ID badge. Yes and in the deleted scenes if you get the DVDs for this, this is a particularly great DVD. So disc 4 in the DVD set disc four has commentary. It has deleted scenes. It has a blooper reel. It has fake PSA's we did. It has Olympic promos we did. It has the accountants, the Webisode series, which won an Emmy. Yeah. So it's got this is a very good disc.
珍娜和我从中赚不到钱。我只是想说，如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，这是一张非常好的碟。珍娜和我从中赚不到钱。我只是想说如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，这是一张很棒的碟。但有一个删减片段我觉得非常有趣。那是迈克尔的谈话头，它有点为整集做了铺垫。是的，我知道你在说什么。事实上，在你解释这个之前，我也想说，我觉得这一集的删减片段就像一集迷你剧。你发现了吗？因为它们以这个开始，就像你在说的，
Jenna and I make no money off this. I'm just telling you, if you're an office fan, this is a very good disc. Jenna and I make no money off this. I'm just telling you if you're an office fan, this is a great disc. But there was a deleted scene that I thought was really interesting. It was a Michael talking head and it kind of sets up the whole episode. Yeah, I know what you're talking about. In fact, I also just want to say before you explain this, I thought that the deleted scenes from this episode played like a mini episode. Did you find that? Because they start with this, like what you're talking about,
它们以迈克尔这个惊人的谈话头开始。完全正确。所以迈克尔在谈论，好吧，其中一件事是他讨厌人们有不对劲的地方却不告诉你哪里不对劲。他说，我爸爸总是那样做。我会看着他说，爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？我会一遍又一遍地做，他只会看着我，好像我是个白痴。他就是这么说的。可怜的迈克尔。然后他和瑞安也有一个场景，他说这只是又一个无聊的日子。什么都不会发生。他在谈论《老大哥》里，
they start with this amazing talking head for Michael. Exactly. So Michael is talking about how, well, one of the things is he hates it when people have something wrong and they won't tell you what's wrong. And he says, my dad would do that all the time. And I would look at him and I'd say, dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? I would do it over and over and he would just look at me like I was an idiot. That's what he says. Poor Michael. And then he also has a scene with Ryan where he is saying that it's just another kind of boring day. Nothing's going to happen. And he's talking about how on Big Brother,
他们每周都处理非常重要的事情，你知道。但我猜那不是现实生活。而且他，你可以看出迈克尔想在这一天感到有成就感。他想感觉自己有所作为。好吧，我认为那个删减片段是一个很好的方式，激发了迈克尔想要在这一天接管办公室冲突解决的整个愿望。因为现在在下一个场景里，瑞安在迈克尔的办公室里，
they tackle really important things, you know, every week. But I guess that's not real life. And he, you can tell that Michael wants to feel accomplished in this day. He wants to feel like he made a difference. Well, I think that deleted scene is a great way that we motivate Michael's whole desire to take over the conflict resolution in the office for the day. Because now in the next scene, Ryan is in Michael's office
他听到奥斯卡在会议室里大喊大叫。奥斯卡要爆发了。我知道那个场景的开头，他们听到奥斯卡说的那些话，奥斯卡是在即兴发挥。因为他们当时就像，好的，只要大惊小怪就行。他们会无意中听到，这会导致他们离开迈克尔的办公室，对吧？
and he hears Oscar yelling from the conference room. Oscar is going off. I know the beginning of that scene, the stuff that they're overhearing Oscar saying, Oscar's improvising. Because they were like, OK, just make a big fuss. They'll overhear it, and it will cause them to leave Michael's office, right?
去看看发生了什么骚动。奥斯卡是一个非常有趣的即兴表演者，他在这一集里玩得很开心。哦，所有那些台词都很棒。迈克尔走进会议室，他看到奥斯卡和托比在一起，他正在咆哮安吉拉的“婴儿爵士”海报。那是托比在圣诞节的秘密圣诞老人交换礼物中给她的。
Go see what the hubbub is about. And Oscar's a very funny improviser, and he got to have some fun in this episode. Oh, all those lines are amazing. Michael goes into the conference room, and he sees Oscar is with Toby, and he is ranting about Angela's baby jazz poster. That Toby gave her in the Secret Santa Exchange at Christmas.
是的。她把它挂在会计部，奥斯卡不想再看了。他很愤怒。托比就像，听着，你通常不会听到这种咆哮。通常我们在休息室做，但他们正在里面拍安保徽章照片。所以我们改在这里做。这是迈克尔的机会。
Yes. She has hung it in accounting, and Oscar doesn't want to look at it anymore. And he's furious. And Toby's like, listen, you normally wouldn't hear this ranting. Normally we do it in the break room, but they're doing the security badge photos in there. So we're doing it in here instead. And this is Michael's opportunity.
他找到了他的目标，就是这个。他太兴奋了。他决定要解决这个冲突。所以他把安吉拉和奥斯卡叫进会议室，帕姆，显然帕姆必须参加。帕姆被迈克尔拉进了太多事情里。就像他需要她以某种方式记录下来。我不知道。但我什么都没写下来。
He has found his purpose and this is it. He's so excited. He decides he's going to resolve this conflict. So he calls Angela and Oscar into the conference room and Pam, apparently Pam had to attend. Pam gets pulled into so many things with Michael. It's like he needs her to document it in some way. I don't know. But I'm not writing anything down.
而且你几乎从来没写过。不，这太真实了。你几乎从来没写过。不。这太真实了。他只是喜欢感觉自己很重要。他喜欢感觉自己有一个私人助理。是的。我喜欢他拿出这个写着“沟通这个活页夹”的海报板的速度。
And you hardly ever are. No, it's so true. you hardly ever are. No. It's so true. He just likes to feel important. He likes to feel like he has a personal assistant. Yes. I like how quickly he produced this poster board that says, communicate this binder.
他一直有这个。他一直在等。他一直有这个。他准备好了。但你知道我在想什么吗，安吉拉？我认为公司很久以前给了他这个活页夹让他翻阅和研究，他直到现在才打开它。哦，是的。他当时就像，我不能被这个活页夹打扰，现在突然他把它从架子上扯了下来。我们有一个
He's had this. He has been waiting. He has had this. He's ready to go. But you know what I think, Angela? I think corporate gave him this binder a long time ago to look through and study and he's never cracked it open until now. Oh yeah. He was like I can't be bothered with this binder and now suddenly he's ripped it off the shelf. We had a
来自艾丹·马吉亚的粉丝提问。你知道我们经历了不同风格的冲突解决。艾丹想知道，剧本里有没有提到五种不同冲突风格中的第二和第三种解决方案是什么？我不知道，但我知道那五种是什么。剧本中提到的唯一一个没有在这个场景中列出的就是妥协。所以五种冲突解决类型是：双输、赢输、妥协、双赢和三赢。所以迈克尔真的专注于三赢，因为那样连他自己也赢了。是的，我们知道双输是第一种，然后安吉拉只是想让他直接跳到双赢，他说，那是第四种。
fan question from Aidan Maggia. You know we go through the different styles of conflict resolution. And Aiden wanted to know, did it ever mention in the script what the number two and number three resolutions were in the five different styles of conflict? I don't know, but I know what the five are. The only one that's referred to in the script that isn't listed in this scene is compromise. So the five types of conflict resolution are lose-lose, win-lose, compromise, win-win, and win-win-win. So they're really, Michael's really keyed in on a win-win-win because then even he wins. Yes, we know lose-lose is number one, and then Angela just wants him to just skip to win-win, and he goes, that's number four.
来自Aidan Maggia的粉丝提问。你知道我们讨论过不同的冲突解决方式。Aidan想知道，剧本里有没有提到五种冲突解决方式中排名第二和第三的是什么？我不知道，但我知道这五种是什么。剧本中提到的唯一一个没有出现在这一幕里的就是妥协。所以这五种冲突解决方式分别是：双输、赢输、妥协、双赢和三赢。迈克尔真的很执着于三赢，因为这样连他自己也能赢。是的，我们知道双输是第一种，然后安吉拉只想让他直接跳到双赢，而他说那是第四种。
But then I love Steve's performance so much when he starts to read number five. And here's the thing that Steve is doing. He's reading something and making it look like he's never read it before, and that he's getting surprised as he reads it. Yes. Even though you and I both know he knew those lines backwards and forwards. So he's like, oh, number five, win, win, win. Oh, I win. I win too because I resolved it. And it's just he's so good. Just in that very like small moment.
但我真的很喜欢史蒂夫在读第五条时的表演。史蒂夫的处理方式是这样的：他读的时候表现得好像他从来没读过一样，而且读的时候还表现出很惊讶的样子。是的。尽管你我都清楚，他对这些台词早已烂熟于心。所以他表现得就像，“哦，第五条，双赢，双赢，双赢。哦，我赢了。我也赢了，因为我解决了这个问题。”他真的太棒了。就在那短短的一瞬间。
You see how great he is at finessing all of these little moments. I love it. They should play that in acting schools as an example of moment of discovery. All right. So at 4 minutes 32 seconds, they go over to, quote, look at the disputed poster. Michael wants them to express their feelings. And I say that the poster makes me happy because it makes me feel like the babies are the real artists that God has a funny sense of humor.
你看他处理这些小细节有多出色。我太喜欢了。表演学校应该把这段作为“发现时刻”的范例播放。好了。在4分32秒，他们去，引用一下，“看那张有争议的海报”。迈克尔想让他们表达自己的感受。我说那张海报让我很高兴，因为它让我觉得婴儿是真正的艺术家，上帝有一种有趣的幽默感。
And Oscar at five minutes, two seconds just goes off. And he has this rant. It was so fun to do this with Oscar. I have known him for so long. We performed together in sketch comedy. So I knew when they told him he could uncork what that meant. And it was just a it was a delight for me when he was like, you know what? It's it's kitsch. It's the opposite of art. It destroys art. It destroys souls. It just goes on. Was that improvised or scripted Angela or a mixture? It was a mixture. It
奥斯卡在5分02秒时彻底爆发了。他发表了一通长篇大论。和奥斯卡一起演这段戏太有趣了。我认识他太久了。我们一起演过小品喜剧。所以我知道当他们告诉他可以“释放”时意味着什么。当他说出“你知道吗？这是媚俗。这是艺术的对立面。它摧毁艺术。它摧毁灵魂。”等等这些话时，我感到非常开心。那是即兴发挥还是剧本写的，安吉拉，还是两者都有？是两者都有。它
was a mixture and I think that was mostly scripted but his stuff with Paul, with Toby in the conference room at the top of that scene was improvised. But Oscar is just so funny in this and I just remember it was hard to keep a straight face. I remember that. I had you to my right and Oscar to my left. It was very hard. It was very hard for me because Pam doesn't have any lines. And my direction was that I was not to react. I was to remain very neutral as possible. And so that was difficult to be neutral. All right. Well, we had a fan question from Zoe Kennedy. What do you guys think a win win win solution to Oscar and Angela's dispute with the baby poster would be?
是两者都有，我认为大部分是剧本写的，但他和保罗，也就是托比，在会议室里那场戏开头的对话是即兴的。但奥斯卡在这段戏里真的太搞笑了，我记得当时很难忍住不笑。我记得。你坐在我右边，奥斯卡在我左边。这太难了。对我来说太难了，因为帕姆没有台词。我的导演要求是我不能有任何反应。我要尽可能保持中立。所以要保持中立很难。好了，我们有一个来自佐伊·肯尼迪的粉丝提问。你们认为奥斯卡和安吉拉关于婴儿海报的纠纷，一个“双赢、双赢、再双赢”的解决方案会是什么？
Because, you know, Michael's win win win solution is that Oscar will turn the baby poster into a T-shirt T-shirt he has to wear because then he won't see it. But Angela will see it all the time. Yes, and neither of them like that. They're like, neither of them like that. So what would you make it be, Ange? What's your win-win-win? I would say that you could have personal items that could fit on your desk. And as long as they weren't offensive, they could stay on your desk. I like that. You shrink it down to like no bigger than an eight by 10. And then she could put it on your desk. I like that you shrink it down to like no bigger than an 8 by 10.
因为，你知道，迈克尔的“双赢、双赢、再双赢”方案是让奥斯卡把婴儿海报做成一件他必须穿的T恤，因为这样他就看不到了。但安吉拉会一直看到它。是的，他们俩都不喜欢这样。他们说，他们俩都不喜欢。那么你会怎么做呢，安吉？你的“双赢、双赢、再双赢”是什么？我会说你可以放一些能放在桌子上的个人物品。只要它们不冒犯人，就可以留在桌子上。我喜欢这个。你把它缩小到不超过8乘10英寸。然后她就可以把它放在你的桌子上了。我喜欢你把它缩小到不超过8乘10英寸。
And then she could put it on her desk and that would be my win win win. Angela, that is a great solution. You set a new rule that personal items can be no larger than 8 by 10. Just that's it. Everyone. You heard it here first. You're welcome, corporate America. You heard it here. All right, so moving on, what is next? So Angela, we got a really cool fan question about this scene from Mari-Sailor Kabuto and I loved it so much, I reached out and I asked her if she would send me
然后她就可以把它放在她的桌子上了，那就会是我的“双赢、双赢、再双赢”。安吉拉，那是个很棒的解决方案。你设定了一个新规则，个人物品不能超过8乘10英寸。就这样。各位。你们在这里先听到了。不客气，美国企业界。你们在这里听到了。好了，继续，接下来是什么？那么安吉拉，我们收到了一个关于这场戏的很酷的粉丝提问，来自玛丽-赛勒·卡布托，我太喜欢了，所以我联系了她，问她是否愿意发给我
a recording of her asking the question. So here it goes. When Michael is trying to solve the Angela Oscar dispute, they are all standing in the accounting area. On a column behind Michael, there is a certificate of participation for a Mark Christie. Who is that? I was so excited to get this question, Angela.
一段她提问的录音。所以开始了。当迈克尔试图解决安吉拉和奥斯卡的纠纷时，他们都站在会计区。在迈克尔身后的一根柱子上，有一张马克·克里斯蒂的参与证书。那是谁？我很高兴收到这个问题，安吉拉。
So this moment happens at 4 minutes 32 seconds. And right next to Steve's head on this pillar, reception is behind the pillar, you can see this plaque. It's exactly what Maricela described. It is a certificate of participation for Mark Christie. This is one of my favorite things about our set. Okay, so Mark was the best boy grip and the key grip for seasons one through three on The Office. And it's the art department that is ultimately responsible for any kind of card, sign, certificate or logo that's created specifically for the show. So our art department created the Dunder Mifflin logo and they created all of the little plaques and signs and certificates that hang around the office.
所以这个时刻发生在4分32秒。就在史蒂夫头旁边的这根柱子上，前台就在柱子后面，你可以看到这个牌匾。这正是玛丽塞拉描述的那样。这是一张马克·克里斯蒂的参与证书。这是我最喜欢我们片场的细节之一。好吧，马克是《办公室》第一季到第三季的最佳场务和灯光组长。艺术部门最终负责为节目专门创作的任何卡片、标志、证书或徽标。所以我们的艺术部门创作了邓德·米夫林的标志，他们创作了挂在办公室周围的所有小牌匾、标志和证书。
And in an effort to give just like a fun personal touch, they would include the names of real crew members. Yes. So for example, we also had a Salesman of the Year and a Humanitarian of the Year plaque. And those plaques featured our crew member names as well. But really, you can see them everywhere. You'll start to notice them as you watch episodes. I do now, I look for them. There are tons that are just sprinkled throughout the whole office.
为了增加一点有趣的个人色彩，他们会加入真实剧组成员的名字。是的。例如，我们还有“年度最佳销售员”和“年度人道主义者”牌匾。这些牌匾也印有我们剧组成员的名字。但实际上，你到处都能看到它们。当你观看剧集时，你会开始注意到它们。我现在会了，我会去找它们。整个办公室里到处都散布着很多。
Well, let me tell you what my favorite one is. Okay. Okay. So my favorite one involves our first AD, Kelly Cantley. You guys might remember her. Kelly, her job is keeping all of the actors on schedule. She makes sure that we arrive for our scenes when we're supposed to. And she is also the one who would run our safety meetings.
好吧，让我告诉你我最喜欢哪一个。好的。好的。我最喜欢的一个涉及我们的第一副导演凯利·坎特利。你们可能还记得她。凯利，她的工作是让所有演员按计划行事。她确保我们按时到达拍摄现场。她也是负责主持安全会议的人。
Yes. So Kelly Cantley was safety meeting, lit candle on set. That's Kelly Cantley. We have a pair of scissors in someone's hand. Safety meeting. Yes, exactly, exactly. But Kelly really had to keep the whole production on time. Everything happening on the set, all of us working together
是的。所以凯利·坎特利就是安全会议，片场点蜡烛。那就是凯利·坎特利。我们有人手里拿着剪刀。安全会议。是的，没错，没错。但凯利确实必须让整个制作按时进行。片场发生的一切，我们所有人一起工作
and getting our day done, making our day. She's by far one of the most important elements to running the show for sure. Well, I guess that Kelly had gone around and looked at all the plaques and she noticed that her name was not on any of them. I could kind of picture Kelly doing that, actually. She spent a couple of days sort of doing this bit where she was all like, oh, I see. No, no, Kelly Cantley. There's my name is on a plaque. It was very funny. And then all of a sudden, one day,
并完成我们的一天，达成目标。她绝对是确保节目顺利运行的最重要因素之一。好吧，我猜凯利到处看了看所有的牌匾，她注意到她的名字没有出现在任何一个上面。我其实能想象凯利那样做。她花了两天时间做这种事，表现得就像，“哦，我明白了。不，不，凯利·坎特利。我的名字在牌匾上。”这太搞笑了。然后突然有一天，
a new plaque showed up. It's on the pole over by Stanley's desk. And here's what it said. It said, whereas it came to our attention that Kelly Cantley was whining that a lowly second assistant director had a plaque with her name on it. And whereas Kelly Cantley made a comment on the air regarding that fact, we have decided to give her this certificate because we love her. So fun. And so and then they just waited for her to notice it. And then it stayed there for the rest of the run of the show. So guys, something fun to
一个新的牌匾出现了。它在斯坦利桌子旁边的柱子上。上面写着：鉴于我们注意到凯利·坎特利在抱怨一个卑微的第二副导演都有一个写着她名字的牌匾。鉴于凯利·坎特利在广播中就这一事实发表了评论，我们决定给她这个证书，因为我们爱她。太有趣了。然后他们就等着她注意到它。然后它就在那里一直挂到了剧集结束。所以伙计们，一些有趣的事情
do. You can go through, try to hit pause whenever you see these certificates and you can see some names of our crew members. I think it's just a really, really great way to honor them. And this is actually a very popular thing that happens on sets. Yes. All right. I think it's just a really, really great way to honor them. And this is actually a very popular thing that happens on sets. Yes. All right. I love that question. I love hearing the behind the scenes of our crew. But Jenna, it's time to get into the save the date. Yes. Six minutes, 28 seconds. We get a real bird's eye view of this. Well,
你可以试着在看到这些证书时按下暂停，你可以看到我们一些剧组成员的名字。我认为这真的是一种非常非常好的纪念他们的方式。这实际上是片场非常流行的事情。是的。好了，我认为这真的是一种非常非常好的纪念他们的方式。这实际上是片场非常流行的事情。是的。好了，我喜欢那个问题。我喜欢听我们剧组的幕后故事。但是珍娜，是时候进入“保存日期”了。是的。6分28秒。我们得到了一个真正的鸟瞰视角。好吧，
Pam has broken down and is giving Angela a save the date hand delivered. We have a fan question from Ms. Lavender Darling. She said Pam's save the date invitations say place TBA. Why did she bother making a save the date with a location? TBD. TBD. When I looked at the save the date, okay, first of all, Angela's throwing shade.
帕姆崩溃了，正在亲手把“保存日期”交给安吉拉。我们有一个来自薰衣草达令女士的粉丝提问。她说帕姆的“保存日期”邀请函上写着地点待定。她为什么要费心制作一个带有地点的“保存日期”？待定。待定。当我看到那个“保存日期”时，好吧，首先，安吉拉在讽刺。
She's like, it's hand delivered, but it's okay. But it's also not my taste. So she's throwing a lot of shade. But I screen grabbed the save the date and it says save the date and then written in hand. So, you know, it's printed, but then you've got to fill in everything by hand. It says for the wedding, Pam Beasley to Roy Anderson,
她说，这是亲手递送的，但没关系。但这也不符合我的品味。所以她在进行大量的讽刺。但我截屏了那个“保存日期”，上面写着“保存日期”，然后是手写的。所以，你知道，它是打印出来的，但你必须手工填写所有内容。上面写着：婚礼，帕姆·比斯利嫁给罗伊·安德森，
date June 10th, place to be determined. This save the date gives us nothing. Everyone in the office knew it was gonna be June 10th because Roy announced it drunkenly on Boo's Cruise. We know it's between the two of you. This save the date is pointless. Yeah. It's a waste of time.
日期6月10日，地点待定。这个“保存日期”什么信息都没给我们。办公室里的每个人都知道会是6月10日，因为罗伊在“布斯游轮”上醉醺醺地宣布了。我们知道是在你们俩之间。这个“保存日期”毫无意义。是的。这是浪费时间。
It's a waste of money. Kind of like their wedding. Oh my god. Can I get an Angela Sass please? I did it. Angela Sass. There it is. I agree with you Angela.
这是浪费金钱。有点像他们的婚礼。天哪。能给我来点安吉拉的毒舌吗？我做了。安吉拉的毒舌。就是这样。我同意你的看法，安吉拉。
I think that these rather lame, handwritten, save the dates are a waste of time. Did you do save the dates for your wedding, or did you just send an invitation? Well, you know, I did just an email save the date. Yeah. I did an email. Yeah, that's a little bit where we are now.
我认为这些相当蹩脚的、手写的“保存日期”是浪费时间。你为你的婚礼做过“保存日期”吗，还是你只是发了请柬？嗯，你知道，我只是发了一个电子邮件的“保存日期”。是的。我发了电子邮件。是的，这就是我们现在所处的情况。
I think I'll say I did a save the date, a hard copy save the date thing, I think. Why? It's a waste of time. I don't know. It's a waste of stamps. It was like etiquette back then. Way back then. No, but it's true. I think there's a lot that has changed. I remember getting in a huge argument with my mom about wedding planning because in her generation, the bride planned the wedding with her parents because her parents paid for the wedding and it was like a party they threw for the bride and groom. And I said, I want to plan my wedding with my husband, the person who's going to be my husband. Like my mom wanted to pick out our registry items with me.
我想我会说我做了一个“保存日期”，一个纸质的“保存日期”，我想。为什么？这是浪费时间。我不知道。这是浪费邮票。那在当时是礼仪。很久以前。不，但这是真的。我认为有很多事情已经改变了。我记得因为婚礼策划和妈妈吵了一架，因为在她那一代，新娘和父母一起策划婚礼，因为父母付钱，这就像他们为新娘和新郎举办的派对。我说，我想和我的丈夫，那个即将成为我丈夫的人一起策划我的婚礼。就像我妈妈想和我一起挑选我们的登记物品。
And I was like, that feels so weird to me that I would go with my mom to pick out my dishes. Wouldn't I go with the person who's going to eat off the plates with me to pick them out? But there was like a generational divide in like how these things are done. And I feel like this is going to point to like another generational divide. Like remember when you used to send these paper save-the-date or even these paper wedding invitations. Nowadays, I get invited to weddings all the time where it's all online.
我觉得和我妈妈一起去挑选餐具太奇怪了。难道我不应该和那个要和我一起用这些盘子吃饭的人一起挑选吗？但在这件事的完成方式上存在代沟。我觉得这会指向另一个代沟。就像记得你过去常寄这些纸质的“保存日期”甚至这些纸质的婚礼请柬吗？现在，我经常被邀请参加婚礼，都是在线的。
I get an email and then I click on this website and the registry links are there and the RSVP is there. And it's like all there and it's actually kind of awesome. I like a lot of it that's online now. It makes it very easy to find information, but I still like getting a hand proper invitation. I don't need to save the date. I don't need a little card with directions. I don't need a little special card that lets you know if I want to eat chicken or the pasta, but I like getting the paper invitation for some of my dearest friends. I've saved them. I don't know. I also am a little bit of a pack rat as we know. I scrapbook. So I like getting the actual paper
我收到一封电子邮件，然后我点击这个网站，登记链接就在那里，回复也在那里。这就像都在那里，实际上还挺棒的。我喜欢现在很多在线的东西。它让查找信息变得非常容易，但我仍然喜欢收到一份正式的纸质请柬。我不需要“保存日期”。我不需要一张带有方向的小卡片。我不需要一张让我知道我想吃鸡肉还是意大利面条的小卡片，但我喜欢收到我最亲密朋友的纸质请柬。我保存了它们。我不知道。我也有一点囤积癖，正如我们所知。我做剪贴簿。所以我喜欢收到实际的纸质
invitation myself. I can be with you on that. I really like getting a paper thank you. Yeah. Like a thank you card in the mail. That's nice. As opposed to for a big event like a wedding. I don't need like a paper thank you if I gave you a birthday present or something. But if it's a big event like a wedding, I think the process of a couple sitting down and writing out their thank you cards is a really nice tradition. And I think it is, hmm, what's the word I'm looking for? Proper? I feel like you're, if you're giving like, yeah, like you're, the significance of a wedding gift deserves the significance of a handwritten thank you card.
请柬。我能和你达成共识。我真的很喜欢收到纸质的感谢信。是的。就像邮寄的感谢卡。那很好。而不是像婚礼这样的大型活动。如果我送了生日礼物什么的，我不需要纸质感谢信。但如果像婚礼这样的大型活动，我认为一对夫妇坐下来写感谢卡是一个非常好的传统。而且我认为它是，嗯，我正在寻找的词是什么？得体？我觉得如果你正在给予，就像，是的，就像你，婚礼礼物的意义值得手写感谢卡的意义。
I can, I can go with that. I can go with that. Well, Angela, I have to say that for being an episode about conflict resolution, we just did not have a conflict about that. We were in total agreement. We talked that out and we agree. You also liked my resolution for the jazz poster. So we're finding some common ground here. Yeah, we're really resolving things.
我能，我能接受这一点。我能接受这一点。好吧，安吉拉，我不得不说，作为一个关于冲突解决的剧集，我们刚才并没有关于那个的冲突。我们完全一致。我们谈过了，我们同意。你也喜欢我为爵士海报提出的解决方案。所以我们在这里找到了一些共同点。是的，我们真的在解决问题。
So there you go. We're on, we're on brand. All right, let's take a break. I'm going to get a snack. All right, we're going to take a break and we will be back. We're gonna take a break and we will be back. Anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. Thursday, May 8th is McHappy Day. When every menu item purchased at McDonald's helps support families with sick children. So you can feel the good that comes from doing good,
所以就是这样。我们，我们符合品牌。好了，休息一下。我要去吃点零食。好了，我们要休息一下，我们会回来的。我们要休息一下，我们会回来的。任何用Uber Eats配送的东西。现在下单。部分市场提供酒精饮料。详情请见应用程序。5月8日星期四是麦当劳的“麦当劳快乐日”。在麦当劳购买的每一件菜单商品都有助于支持患病儿童的家庭。所以你可以感受到做好事带来的美好，
just from ordering. So if I order a Big Mac, I'm helping. Yup. What about a McFlurry? 10 piece chicken McNuggets and apple pie? You got it. Every single order helps. Join us at McDonald's for McHappy Day on Thursday, May 8th.
仅仅通过点餐。所以如果我点一个巨无霸，我就是在帮忙。是的。那麦旋风呢？10块麦乐鸡和苹果派？没问题。每一笔订单都有帮助。加入我们在5月8日星期四的麦当劳“麦当劳快乐日”。
Do good, feel good. A portion of food and beverage sales will support RMHC chapters in local children's charities across Canada. Craving an escape? Bring the vibrant flavors of Mexican street eat energy to life in your kitchen with Tia Rosa Tortillas. Born in Mexico, Tia Rosa knows how to turn your next taco night at home into the real deal. Find Tia Rosa Tortillas at select grocery stores and get the good vibes going.
做好事，感觉良好。部分食品和饮料销售额将支持加拿大各地的RMHC分会和当地儿童慈善机构。渴望逃离？用Tia Rosa玉米饼在你的厨房里让墨西哥街头美食的活力风味变得栩栩如生。诞生于墨西哥，Tia Rosa知道如何让你在家里的下一个塔可之夜变得地道。在精选杂货店找到Tia Rosa玉米饼，让好心情持续下去。
Tia Rosa, Tia Rosa. Okay, we are back from break. We have discussed Pam's very lame save the date. Yeah. And now Michael fresh off his, I guess his win, win, win with Oscar and Angela decides he's going to demand from Toby that he be given all of the unresolved complaints, all of them. And he takes them from Toby forcibly. He says, quote, I had to use win-lose on that. It was not pretty.
Tia Rosa，Tia Rosa。好了，我们休息回来了。我们讨论了帕姆非常蹩脚的“保存日期”。是的。现在迈克尔刚从他与奥斯卡和安吉拉的“双赢、双赢、再双赢”中走出来，决定要求托比把所有未解决的投诉都交给他，全部。他强行从托比那里拿走了它们。他说，引用一下，“我不得不对那个使用双输。那并不好看。”
Yeah. But now he's got them and he is gonna start resolving conflicts. He's just gonna stir the pot. That's what he's gonna do. At seven minutes and 40 seconds, Pam is in the conference room with Michael and they're going through all the complaints.
是的。但现在他拿到了它们，他要开始解决冲突了。他只是要搅浑水。这就是他要做的。在7分40秒，帕姆和迈克尔在会议室里，他们正在查看所有的投诉。
And I have to say, and in this scene I really liked the callback for Stanley with miracle whip. Did you hear that one? Yes. The complaint that is from Kevin that Stanley keeps using his miracle whip without asking, which is a callback from when Jim was doing that Stanley impression during drug testing. And he, his bit was, I like the tangy zip of miracle whip. Yeah.
我不得不说，在这场戏里，我真的很喜欢斯坦利关于奇迹鞭酱（Miracle Whip）的呼应。你听到了吗？是的。凯文的投诉是斯坦利在没问的情况下一直用他的奇迹鞭酱，这是对吉姆在药物测试期间模仿斯坦利时的呼应。他的台词是，“我喜欢奇迹鞭酱那种刺鼻的口感。”是的。
Yeah. I love that. Um, so also there's something else that I think was pretty fantastic. If you love a really good eye roll, you need to go to eight minutes, 35 seconds. Angela, I wrote it down too. There is a Pam I roll to end all I rolls. It is substantial. It is. Well, Michael has gone into the bullpen to ask people if they feel like Toby really solved their complaints or if they
是的。我喜欢那个。嗯，还有一些我认为非常棒的事情。如果你喜欢一个非常好的翻白眼，你需要去8分35秒。安吉拉，我也记下来了。有一个帕姆的翻白眼，终结了所有的翻白眼。它是实质性的。它是。好吧，迈克尔已经进入办公区询问人们是否觉得托比真的解决了他们的投诉，或者他们
were merely listened to and forgot about and he starts reading all the complaints out loud. And that's when I wrote down major Pam I roll SAS. Some major Pam SAS right there. And so then there's this thing I remember laughing. I remember breaking in this at 8 minutes 53 seconds. Michael says, oh, and there's a Phyllis Angela dispute. And I say, you already did me. And he goes, that's what she said.
只是被听取了然后被遗忘了，他开始大声朗读所有的投诉。那就是我写下“主要的帕姆翻白眼毒舌”的时候。那里有一些主要的帕姆毒舌。然后有件事我记得我笑了。我记得在8分53秒这里我破功了。迈克尔说，“哦，还有一个菲利斯和安吉拉的纠纷。”我说，“你已经做过我了。”他说，“那是她说的。”
And Jim mouths it as Michael says it. Yeah. That was scripted. That was not John improvising. That was a scripted moment. And the camera sort of pretends like it's going to find John doing that. It's really great.
吉姆在迈克尔说的时候跟着对口型。是的。那是剧本写的。那不是约翰即兴发挥的。那是一个剧本时刻。摄像机假装它要找到约翰在做那个。这真的很棒。
I think that's a great example of the choreography with the camera. The discovery moment. Yeah, exactly. We also find out some interesting information about Dwight and Angela. Yes. Which is we now have a timestamp because for six months Angela has been complaining about Dwight and that that was all redacted for the last six months. Yes, all of Angela's complaints about Dwight were redacted six months ago. Six months. I'd love to read what some of those complaints were. Well, we know one of them. One of them has to do with safety officer. I'm sure she filed a complaint about that. I'm sure all of her complaints are just based on who is really in charge of this or that. But now Michael just starts listing things off and he's one by one getting
我认为这是摄像机编排的一个很好的例子。发现时刻。是的，没错。我们还发现了一些关于德怀特和安吉拉的有趣信息。是的。也就是我们现在有一个时间戳，因为六个月来安吉拉一直在抱怨德怀特，而那在过去六个月里都被删减了。是的，安吉拉所有关于德怀特的投诉在六个月前都被删减了。六个月。我很想读读那些投诉是什么。好吧，我们知道其中一个。其中一个与安全官有关。我敢肯定她为此投诉过。我敢肯定她所有的投诉都只是基于谁才是真正负责这个或那个的人。但现在迈克尔开始列举事情，他一个接一个地让
everyone pissed off at each other. Everyone is getting angry with each other. Pam first volunteers to save Angela because it seems like it's going to be revealed to the office. If anyone thinks real hard on this that, hmm, why did Angela redact all of her complaints? Only Dwight. Yeah, only Dwight. So Pam volunteers, but there's only one complaint against Pam, and it's been withdrawn.
每个人都对彼此感到愤怒。每个人都对彼此感到生气。帕姆首先自愿去救安吉拉，因为如果有人认真思考这个问题，似乎它会被揭露给办公室，嗯，为什么安吉拉删减了她所有的投诉？只有德怀特。是的，只有德怀特。所以帕姆自愿，但只有一个针对帕姆的投诉，而且已经被撤回了。
And this was the complaint. Does she have to plan her wedding on office time? Can't she do that from home? And Pam assumes that it was Angela who complained about her. Pam totally glares at Angela and Angela's like, what? What? Like, and I believe her. I believe her. Well, yeah, she didn't complain about her. No. Yeah. But I think it's reasonable for Pam to assume that she did. Well, true, because Angela, I I think has the most complaints of anyone else
这就是投诉。她必须在办公时间策划她的婚礼吗？她不能在家做吗？帕姆认为投诉她的人是安吉拉。帕姆完全怒视安吉拉，安吉拉就像，“什么？什么？”就像，我相信她。我相信她。好吧，是的，她没有投诉她。不。是的。但我认为帕姆认为她投诉了是很合理的。好吧，真的，因为安吉拉，我，我认为是所有人中投诉最多的
Yes in the complaint box. This is true, but you're right Then Michael goes around and just starts throwing out all of everybody's complaints We have to point out that at 10 minutes 53 seconds. We have an Angela Pam Partition scene. I love it these were some of my favorites and we we didn't get to do very many of them because we would laugh and we would ruin take after take but here it is you and I over the partition having a heated conversation. Yes Pam goes right up to Angela and says thanks for ratting me out. I know you're
是的，在投诉箱里。这是真的，但你是对的。然后迈克尔走了一圈，开始抛出所有人的投诉。我们必须指出，在10分53秒，我们有一个安吉拉和帕姆的隔板戏。我喜欢它，这些是我最喜欢的戏份之一，我们没有机会做太多，因为我们会笑，我们会毁掉一个又一个镜头，但就在这里，你和我隔着隔板进行激烈的谈话。是的，帕姆直接走到安吉拉面前说，“谢谢你告发我。”我知道你
so ticked off. Oh I'm mad. Fan question from Colleen Keenan and Brittany Magert. They both asked, was Pam calling Dwight Bobblehead Joe scripted? Because I say, you and Bobblehead Joe. I know. They want to know if that was scripted. It was scripted. It was scripted.
太生气了。哦，我很生气。来自科琳·基南和布列塔尼·马格特的粉丝提问。她们都问，帕姆叫德怀特“摇头娃娃乔”是剧本写的吗？因为我说，“你和摇头娃娃乔。”我知道。她们想知道那是否是剧本写的。那是剧本写的。那是剧本写的。
But guess what? Here's a little window into Pam. When she gets mad, she starts name calling. I guess so. Can I get a, Sam, could I get a little Pam sass here? Pam sass. Thank you. Yeah, that's appropriate.
但猜猜怎么着？这是帕姆的一点窗口。当她生气时，她开始骂人。我想是吧。能给我来点，萨姆，能给我来点帕姆的毒舌吗？帕姆毒舌。谢谢。是的，那很合适。
Pam sass. Because Pam keeps sassing. She sasses right into the kitchen and is complaining to Jim about Angela. And Jim's kind of like, oh, I don't know. He doesn't know. You know what I wish? I wish we had a sting that said, Jim shade, because he gives you some shade.
帕姆毒舌。因为帕姆一直在毒舌。她一直毒舌到厨房，向吉姆抱怨安吉拉。吉姆有点像，“哦，我不知道。”他不知道。你知道我希望什么吗？我希望我们有一个刺耳的音效，说“吉姆讽刺”，因为他给了你一些讽刺。
He's like, oh, and what does Roy think about that? And she's like, well, I don't really talk to Roy about this. And he's like, about your feelings and stuff. Yeah. Jamshade. I like it, Angela. I like it. Well, now we move into the conference room.
他说，“哦，罗伊对此怎么看？”她说，“嗯，我真的不和罗伊谈论这个。”他说，“关于你的感受之类的。”是的。吉姆讽刺。我喜欢它，安吉拉。我喜欢它。好吧，现在我们进入会议室。
Angela, can you tell us about this scene with you and Phyllis with Michael? This scene was really hard because Phyllis and I got tickled. We got tickled. But yeah, so here, Angela and Phyllis are added again. Now, in the bullpen, when Michael calls out Phyllis for having a complaint on Angela,
安吉拉，你能告诉我们关于你和菲利斯与迈克尔的这场戏吗？这场戏真的很难，因为菲利斯和我被逗乐了。我们被逗乐了。但是的，所以在这里，安吉拉和菲利斯又开始了。现在，在办公区，当迈克尔指出菲利斯对安吉拉有投诉时，
she's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Angela and I are friends. But then Phyllis just starts turning on everyone. There's a deleted scene. That's also pretty great. So yeah, so Phyllis clearly, I guess, has been parking in the parking spot where Angela likes to park. Even though they're not named parking spots, we don't have individual spots. But clearly, my character likes to park in the same spot every day, and
她说，“我不知道你在说什么。安吉拉和我是朋友。”但随后菲利斯就开始攻击每个人。有一个删减片段。那也相当棒。所以是的，所以菲利斯显然，我猜，一直停在安吉拉喜欢停的停车位上。尽管它们不是指定的停车位，我们没有个人车位。但显然，我的角色喜欢每天停在同一个位置，而
Phyllis has been parking in it. And I'm ticked off, so I complained complained and Phyllis is like I'm sorry I guess I forgot I parked in the spot you liked even though we don't have a signed parking but then at the very end she goes I don't like you I know and in the deleted scene she tells Dwight she doesn't like him hmm I think that's some Phyllis sass Phyllis s sass. That one's hard. It's a lot of it's like it's a lot of s's. This is when we're gonna find out that Ryan thinks Creed has an old man smell and Creed is like oh yeah oh yeah I know what he's talking about. I grow mung beans in my desk. They're really nutritious, but they smell like death. I texted Creed last night about it. And? Does he eat them in
菲利斯一直停在那里。我很生气，所以我投诉了，投诉了，菲利斯就像，“对不起，我想我忘了我停在你喜欢的车位了，尽管我们没有指定的停车位。”但最后她说，“我不喜欢你。”我知道，在删减片段中，她告诉德怀特她不喜欢他。嗯，我想那是菲利斯的毒舌。菲利斯毒舌。那个很难。它有很多，就像有很多“s”。这是我们要发现瑞安认为克里德有老人味的时候，克里德就像，“哦，是的，哦，是的，我知道他在说什么。我在桌子里种绿豆。它们非常有营养，但闻起来像死亡。”我昨晚给克里德发短信问这件事。然后呢？他吃它们吗？在
real life? I said Creed, you're on my TV right now talking about the mung beans in your drawer. And he said, I still talk to my mung beans. Oh Creed. And he said, yeah. He said, I was eating mung beans exactly. That's exactly what it was. Wow. I said, how do they taste? And he said, they taste like grass and air mostly. Grass and air. Not really like death.
现实生活中？我说，“克里德，你现在在我的电视上谈论你抽屉里的绿豆。”他说，“我仍然和我的绿豆说话。”哦，克里德。他说，“是的。”他说，“我正在吃绿豆，没错。”那正是它。哇。我说，“它们味道如何？”他说，“它们尝起来主要是草和空气的味道。”草和空气。并不是真的像死亡。
Well, Angela, I looked up mung beans and it turns out that they are really good for you, especially the sprouted ones. Oh, the sprouted ones have fewer calories and more amino acids and antioxidants than unsprouted ones. Let me tell you some benefits to eating mung beans because I know you're curious. I can't wait. So they've done some studies in animals that have shown that mung beans helped to reduce cholesterol Okay, we're not doctors. I'm just a woman on the internet. So anything I say here right now
好吧，安吉拉，我查了绿豆，结果发现它们对你真的很好，尤其是发芽的那些。哦，发芽的那些比没发芽的含有更少的卡路里和更多的氨基酸和抗氧化剂。让我告诉你吃绿豆的一些好处，因为我知道你很好奇。我等不及了。所以他们在动物身上做了一些研究，表明绿豆有助于降低胆固醇。好吧，我们不是医生。我只是互联网上的一个女人。所以此时此刻我说的任何话
Yeah, she's just a woman talking to you from her closet. A little disclaimer, but they also seem to be a good source of potassium, magnesium, protein and fiber But here's the catch. If you are sprouting mung beans properly, and you let them drain, and then you rinse them off after you've let them soak, they won't smell. Only neglected mung beans stink. So Creed had some neglected mung beans in a
是的，她只是一个从衣柜里跟你说话的女人。一个小免责声明，但它们似乎也是钾、镁、蛋白质和纤维的良好来源。但问题来了。如果你正确地发绿豆芽，并且你让它们排水，然后在浸泡后把它们冲洗干净，它们就不会有味道。只有被忽视的绿豆才会发臭。所以克里德在
stusk. And that's why they smelled so badly. So anyway, I guess I just want people to know that if you've ever been curious about sprouting and eating some mung beans, they won't be stinky if you just care for them properly. According to the internet, I'm not an expert. And according to Creed, they taste like grass and air. So there you go. All right. Kevin has been making sexually suggestive comments to Angela that make her uncomfortable. So Michael suggests that the solution is for Angela to make sexual comments about Kevin that will make him uncomfortable.
桌子里有一些被忽视的绿豆。这就是为什么它们闻起来那么糟糕。所以无论如何，我想让人们知道，如果你曾经对发芽和吃一些绿豆感到好奇，只要你正确地照顾它们，它们就不会发臭。根据互联网，我不是专家。而且根据克里德，它们尝起来像草和空气。所以就是这样。好了。凯文一直对安吉拉发表性暗示评论，让她感到不舒服。所以迈克尔建议解决方案是让安吉拉对凯文发表性评论，让他感到不舒服。
First of all, Kevin Gross, once again, we have been tracking Kevin's perviness. Is that a sting? Kevin perv. Our whole podcast is just gonna be stings. It's gonna be like Angela Sass, Kevin perv, Pam Shade. Okay, now we're back in the break room. We're back to making our IDs and our badges, right? And at 13 minutes, 11 seconds, my stepson Jack, it's one of his favorite talking heads,
首先，凯文真恶心，再一次，我们一直在追踪凯文的色狼行为。那是一个刺耳的音效吗？凯文色狼。我们的整个播客都将只是刺耳的音效。它会像安吉拉毒舌，凯文色狼，帕姆讽刺。好的，现在我们回到休息室。我们回到制作我们的身份证和徽章，对吧？在13分11秒，我的继子杰克，这是他最喜欢的谈话头之一，
where Dwight said he would never smile in a photo because that's a sign of weakness. And so he's never going to smile in a photo, which just cracked us up. Jim is making this oversized ID badge for Dwight. He's playing a prank on them, you guys. This is classic Jim, right? And he put Dwight's middle name as on them you guys. This is classic Jim, right? Yeah, you know put Dwight's middle name is fart Yep, and he says he's a security threat. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, we had a fan catch by Molly Torres She says at 14 minutes 42 seconds
德怀特说他永远不会在照片里微笑，因为那是软弱的标志。所以他永远不会在照片里微笑，这让我们笑得前仰后合。吉姆正在为德怀特制作这个超大的身份证。他在捉弄他们，伙计们。这是经典的吉姆，对吧？他把德怀特中间的名字写成在捉弄他们，伙计们。这是经典的吉姆，对吧？是的，你知道把德怀特中间的名字写成“屁”。是的，他说他是一个安全威胁。嗯哼。是的。好吧，我们有一个来自莫莉·托雷斯的粉丝发现。她说在14分42秒
there is a close-up shot of the prank ID badge that Jim made for Dwight and his title is Assistant to the regional manager. But he had been promoted to assistant regional manager in season two, episode six. This is another layer to Jim's prank. Yes, so it goes unmentioned in the episode, but yes, another layer to the prank badge is that he gives him his improper title.
有一个吉姆为德怀特制作的恶作剧身份证的特写镜头，他的头衔是“区域经理助理”。但他已经在第二季第六集被提升为“区域助理经理”了。这是吉姆恶作剧的另一层含义。是的，所以它在剧集中没有被提及，但是的，恶作剧徽章的另一层含义是他给了他错误的头衔。
That he loves to do. Yes, that's right. Well, it's at this point that Dwight storms over to Toby. He's had enough. And he finds out that Toby has just been putting his complaints about Jim in a box. He has not been registering them with corporate the way he said. Now Dwight is furious and he goes marching in to find Michael. And he says a line that I love, four years of malfeasances.
他喜欢这样做。是的，没错。好吧，就在这时，德怀特冲向托比。他受够了。他发现托比一直把关于吉姆的投诉放在一个盒子里。他并没有像他说的那样向公司登记。现在德怀特非常愤怒，他大步走进去找迈克尔。他说了一句我喜欢的台词，“四年的渎职。”
Yes. Yes. And he says, I cannot work with Jim anymore. One of them has to go. Michael has to pick by the end of the day. Yeah, he is officially furious. And you know what? This is all coming back to bite Michael in the butt
是的。是的。他说，“我不能再和吉姆一起工作了。必须走一个。”迈克尔必须在一天结束前做出选择。是的，他正式愤怒了。你知道吗？这一切都回来咬迈克尔的屁股了
because Toby said, just let him vent. And then I file it and I never do anything about it. And they got to vent and that's that. And now it's all catching up with Michael. He realizes that Toby probably had the right idea. Yes. Well, Dwight goes online and starts looking up jobs at other branches. And Dunderpedia had a really great list of all the jobs that are available. At 14 minutes 56 seconds, if you pause on the screen, here are the jobs that are available within Dunder Mifflin. Are you
因为托比说，“让他发泄吧。然后我归档，我从来不做任何处理。”他们发泄了，就这样。现在这一切都追上了迈克尔。他意识到托比可能想对了。是的。好吧，德怀特上网开始寻找其他分公司的工作。邓德百科有一个非常好的所有可用工作的列表。在14分56秒，如果你在屏幕上暂停，这里是邓德·米夫林内部可用的工作。你
ready? At Stanford there is a plant manager and a sales manager position. The sales manager position requires three to five years of experience and a bachelor's degree and there is an IT manager position available at Stanford. Here's my question. Isn't Josh Porter the, oh, is he the branch manager? He's the branch manager. Well, within our office, I guess, Michael is the branch manager. Who's the sales manager of Scranton?
准备好了吗？在斯坦福有一个工厂经理和一个销售经理职位。销售经理职位需要三到五年经验和学士学位，斯坦福还有一个IT经理职位。这是我的问题。乔什·波特不是，哦，他是分公司经理吗？他是分公司经理。好吧，在我们的办公室里，我猜，迈克尔是分公司经理。斯克兰顿的销售经理是谁？
Probably, I mean, I don't know. Like Stanley? I would think Stanley because he's a senior. Yeah, he's been there a while. Yeah. But that's a job we don't ever really talk about. We never discuss. Yeah.
可能，我的意思是，我不知道。就像斯坦利？我想会是斯坦利，因为他是资深的。是的，他在那里待了一段时间。是的。但那是我们从来不真正谈论的工作。我们从来不讨论。是的。
So I just thought that was interesting. Well, in New York Dunder Mifflin, they've got a position for maintenance engineer. In Albany, they need a comptroller and two regional managers. And in Buffalo, you can't read what it is, but they need someone. And Scranton has two positions available. Well, here's the thing. For a company that's downsizing and on the verge of collapse, why are all of these job openings? What's up? Thank you. That too. But listen to the jobs that are available in Scranton.
所以我只是觉得这很有趣。好吧，在纽约邓德·米夫林，他们有一个维护工程师的职位。在奥尔巴尼，他们需要一名审计长和两名区域经理。在布法罗，你读不出是什么，但他们需要人。斯克兰顿有两个职位空缺。好吧，问题是。对于一家正在裁员且濒临倒闭的公司，为什么会有这么多职位空缺？怎么回事？谢谢。那个也是。但听听斯克兰顿有哪些工作。
Warehouse staff and warehouse manager. But isn't Darryl the warehouse manager? Is he looking to leave? What's happening there? What's the story? I don't know. I don't know because he is the manager. After this Michael calls Dwight and Jim into the conference room and he goes through a list of Dwight's complaints. And this is my favorite part of the episode. It's so good. And one of them made me laugh so hard. All right.
仓库员工和仓库经理。但达里尔不是仓库经理吗？他想离开吗？那里发生了什么？故事是什么？我不知道。我不知道，因为他是经理。在此之后，迈克尔把德怀特和吉姆叫到会议室，他列举了德怀特的投诉清单。这是我这一集最喜欢的部分。太棒了。其中一个让我笑得太厉害了。好了。
Here are the list of pranks that Jim has pulled on Dwight that Dwight has reported. Ready? Okay. Yes. Ready, Jenna? Go. Number one. Number one, he replaced all of Dwight's pens and pencils with crayons. Number two, he had everyone call him Dwayne all day, which by the way, Jenna, by the way, guess who would sometimes call him Dwayne? Who? In a scene. Who? Oscar. He did? For real. For real, there were scenes where he'd be like, listen, Dwayne.
这是吉姆对德怀特进行的恶作剧清单，德怀特报告了。准备好了吗？好的。是的。准备好了吗，珍娜？开始。第一。第一，他把德怀特所有的钢笔和铅笔都换成了蜡笔。第二，他让每个人整天叫他“德韦恩”，顺便说一句，珍娜，顺便说一句，猜猜谁有时会叫他德韦恩？谁？在戏里。谁？奥斯卡。他做了吗？真的。真的，有几场戏他会说，“听着，德韦恩。”
I'd be like, Dwight. It's Dwight. And he'd be like, ah, crap. That is so funny. Somehow it went into Oscar's brain in real life. OK. Well, Jim also placed a bloody glove in Dwight's desk drawer and tried to convince him that he had committed murder.
我会说，“德怀特。是德怀特。”他会说，“啊，该死。”这太搞笑了。不知何故，它在现实生活中进入了奥斯卡的脑子。好的。好吧，吉姆还在德怀特的抽屉里放了一只血手套，试图说服他犯了谋杀罪。
Yes. Number four, Jim told Dwight there was an abandoned infant in the women's room. He went in to save the child and saw Meredith on the can. Yes. This one is my favorite of all time of any prank ever written about on The Office. It's just a sentence. We never see this play out, but my imagination of it is so rich. Dwight says he hit himself in the head with his phone. And Michael is like, what? How could that
是的。第四，吉姆告诉德怀特女厕所里有一个被遗弃的婴儿。他进去救那个孩子，看到梅雷迪思在马桶上。是的。这是我最喜欢的，关于《办公室》写过的任何恶作剧。它只是一个句子。我们从来没看到它上演，但我的想象力非常丰富。德怀特说他用手机打了自己的头。迈克尔就像，“什么？怎么可能
have been Jim's fault? And then Jim in his talking head. And John's reaction, he laughs. He says that he put nickels in Dwight's headset over the course of a long time so that it got heavier and heavier. And then one day he took them all out so that when Dwight answered the phone, it would be super light. That is brilliant. That is brilliant. Greg Daniels. Yeah, clap. That is brilliant.
是吉姆的错？”然后吉姆在谈话头里。约翰的反应，他笑了。他说他在很长一段时间里在德怀特的耳机里放了镍币，所以它变得越来越重。然后有一天他把它们全拿走了，所以当德怀特接电话时，它会变得超级轻。这太天才了。这太天才了。格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的，鼓掌。这太天才了。
And that is Jim doing the slow play. That is, that's I think why I like it is the patience required for that prank. All right. There's more. Go. The next one is that every time Dwight typed his name, it would just say diaper. Diapers. Yeah. And then the last one is that by the end of the day, Dwight complains that his desk was moved two feet closer to the copier. And Jim admits that yes, every time Jim got up from his desk, he moved it a little closer to the copier.
那是吉姆在玩慢节奏。那是，我想这就是我喜欢它的原因，是那个恶作剧所需的耐心。好了。还有更多。开始。下一个是每次德怀特输入他的名字，它只会显示“尿布”。尿布。是的。最后一点是，到了一天结束时，德怀特抱怨他的桌子被移到了离复印机近两英尺的地方。吉姆承认，是的，每次吉姆从桌子上站起来，他都会把它往复印机那边移近一点。
But then Jim was like, well, when you when you put them all together like that, it doesn't sound really cool. Yeah, he's like, oh, that sounds like maybe my life is gonna suck. Yeah, maybe I suck. That's what I spent my time doing. At 16 minutes 39 seconds, I have a card that it just says, a montage of sass. Oh, it's your montage of sass. It's a montage of sass. We see Phyllis, she slams the fridge door on Angela. Pam is glaring, eating yogurt, angry, eating yogurt, angry eating yogurt. And then you have like Creed and he's looking crazy and he's holding a pencil like it's a knife. And I mean, then it just goes all through Stanley and Kevin and Kelly and Toby, everyone is ticked off.
但后来吉姆就像，“嗯，当你把它们放在一起时，听起来并不酷。”是的，他就像，“哦，听起来好像我的生活会很糟糕。”是的，也许我很烂。这就是我花时间做的事情。在16分39秒，我有一张卡片，上面写着，“毒舌蒙太奇”。哦，这是你的毒舌蒙太奇。这是毒舌蒙太奇。我们看到菲利斯，她把冰箱门摔在安吉拉身上。帕姆在怒视，吃酸奶，生气，吃酸奶，生气地吃酸奶。然后你有像克里德，他看起来很疯狂，他拿着一支铅笔就像它是刀一样。我的意思是，然后它一直经过斯坦利、凯文、凯利和托比，每个人都很生气。
Yeah, everyone's just mad. It's a mad montage. It's a sass montage, really. It's a montage of sass. It is. Well, at 18 really. It's a montage of sass. It is. Well, at 18 minutes, we have a fan catch from George Felton. Okay. Dwight's ID badge has been redone.
是的，每个人都很生气。这是一个愤怒的蒙太奇。这真的是一个毒舌蒙太奇。这是一个毒舌蒙太奇。它是。好吧，在18真的。这是一个毒舌蒙太奇。它是。好吧，在18分钟，我们有一个来自乔治·费尔顿的粉丝发现。好的。德怀特的身份证被重做了。
His middle name is correct. It says Kurt. But you know what? If you look closely, he's still listed as a security threat. He didn't get that removed. Good catch, George. I liked that. There is a deleted scene where Pam shows Jim her ID badge,
他的中间名是正确的。它写着库尔特。但你知道吗？如果你仔细看，他仍然被列为安全威胁。他没有把它移除。好发现，乔治。我喜欢那个。有一个删减片段，帕姆向吉姆展示她的身份证，
and her clearance level is red. Yeah. And Jim's like, what does that mean? And Dwight's like, I'm not going to tell you. Also, Pam doesn't seem to know what it means either, which I thought was very funny. All right, so guys, it's the end of the day and Michael thinks that the way he could really boost everyone's morale after this hard day of resolving conflicts is to get a group photo. He wants a group photo.
她的权限级别是红色。是的。吉姆就像，“那是什么意思？”德怀特就像，“我不会告诉你的。”而且，帕姆似乎也不知道那是什么意思，我觉得这非常有趣。好了，伙计们，一天结束了，迈克尔认为在解决冲突的艰难一天后，他真正能提振大家士气的方法是拍一张集体照。他想要一张集体照。
Stanley's like, are you kidding me? Like, seriously? So he gets everybody to stand, but a lot's happening. Like no one's smiling. This is when Jim tells Pam that he's the one who made the complaint against her about the wedding thing. And how awkward. He was just venting. Oh my God, so awkward. How awkward he's having this conversation during a group photo of his coworkers.
斯坦利心想，你在开玩笑吗？认真的吗？于是他让大家都站好，但现场情况很混乱。没人笑得出来。就在这时，吉姆告诉帕姆，关于婚礼的事，是他向公司投诉了她。太尴尬了。他当时只是在发泄。天哪，太尴尬了。他在同事合影时进行这种谈话，真是太尴尬了。
And you're like sandwiched between Phyllis and Stanley and Phyllis is listening to everything. Her reactions are amazing. So good. She literally says, oh dear. Yes, yes. I have a fan catch, another fan catch from Carly Mitchell. You know how earlier you were mentioning how your stepson Jack loves that talking head where Dwight says he doesn't smile because it's a sign of weakness and primates? Yeah. Guess who's smiling in the group photo? Who? Dwight. Dwight? Yeah. Dwight what are you doing? Fan catch by Carly Mitchell 18
你就像被夹在菲利斯和斯坦利中间，而菲利斯把一切都听进去了。她的反应太棒了。真的太好了。她居然说，噢天哪。没错，没错。我还有一个粉丝发现，来自卡莉·米切尔。你记得之前提到过你继子杰克很喜欢德怀特那个采访片段吗？德怀特说他不笑是因为那是灵长类动物软弱的表现。没错。猜猜谁在合影里笑了？谁？德怀特。德怀特？没错。德怀特，你在干什么？粉丝发现者：卡莉·米切尔，18分50秒。
minutes 50 seconds. He's smiling. You know what? I feel like this is like layered, like emotionally for Dwight because he would not smile on his own, but he will smile for Michael. And that is his weakness. Michael is his weakness.
他在笑。你知道吗？我觉得这对德怀特来说是有多重情感含义的，因为他自己不会笑，但他会为了迈克尔而笑。这就是他的软肋。迈克尔是他的软肋。
Oh, yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch. Okay. For this group photo moment. You know, Michael says it's really hard to get a photo of 15 people. Yeah. He says, that's really hard.
噢，没错。好吧，我有一个“珍娜发现”。好的。关于这张合影的时刻。你知道，迈克尔说要拍15个人的照片真的很难。没错。他说，那真的很难。
Guess what? There's only 14 people in the photo. Ha ha ha ha. Jenna Ketch. Jenna Ketch. Ha ha ha. There you go. I love it, I love it. Well, and it's true.
你猜怎么着？照片里只有14个人。哈哈哈哈。珍娜发现。珍娜发现。哈哈。就是这样。我喜欢，我喜欢。嗯，这是真的。
He never does get a photo. So he Photoshopped the group photo. He says it's amazing what you can do with Photoshop. And that's how he gets his group photo. And as you guys know, because we've shared with you, Greg then gave that photo to us all as a gift. And I have it. I will put it, I will hold up the photo of it next to me
他确实没拍到照片。所以他用Photoshop处理了合影。他说Photoshop的功能真是太神奇了。他就是这样得到了他的合影。正如你们所知，因为我们和你们分享过，格雷格后来把那张照片作为礼物送给了我们所有人。我有那张照片。我会把它放在我身边，举起照片，
and put it on the website. So then this episode ends. It's kind of sad. Pam is checking her voicemail and she gets this voicemail from Jim saying, you know what, I'm not gonna be in until the afternoon tomorrow because I have a doctor's appointment in the city.
然后把它放到网站上。这集就这样结束了。有点伤感。帕姆在查语音信箱，她收到了吉姆的留言，说，你知道吗，我明天下午才能来上班，因为我要去城里看医生。
But then we see what he's really doing. He's meeting with Jan at corporate. Yeah. And you know, he's probably going to apply for that job at the Stanford branch. He can't take it anymore. He can't watch her plan her wedding anymore. It's getting to be too much and it's heartbreaking. Yeah, he's gonna move on. The very end of this episode is an amazing little tribute to Raiders of the Lost Ark. It is.
但随后我们看到了他真正的去向。他在公司总部和简见面。没错。而且你知道，他可能要去申请斯坦福分部的那份工作了。他受够了。他再也无法看着她筹备婚礼了。这变得太沉重了，令人心碎。没错，他要继续前行了。这一集的结尾是对《夺宝奇兵》的一个精彩小致敬。确实是。
Where we see Toby putting this box of complaints in a wall of complaints, like with the forklift and the whole thing, it's very Raiders of the Lost Ark. Yes, we had a fan ask, Cole Edwards wanted to know, at the end of the episode, when we see Toby put that box of complaints in the warehouse, was it an homage to the end of Indiana Jones? It was.
我们看到托比用叉车把那箱投诉信放进投诉墙里，整个过程非常像《夺宝奇兵》。没错，有粉丝问，科尔·爱德华兹想知道，在这一集结尾，当我们看到托比把那箱投诉信放进仓库时，那是对《夺宝奇兵》结局的致敬吗？确实是。
Yes, it was. And you guys, just for fun, if you're out there and you're going to re-watch it, go to 11 minutes, 43 seconds. Toby's company ID photo is my favorite. What is it? He sits down and he just says, just take the picture. And he gets up and walks away. Oh, yes. He takes it right as he walks away.
是的，没错。伙计们，为了好玩，如果你们还在看的话，去看看11分43秒。托比的公司证件照是我的最爱。是什么？他坐下来，只是说，快拍吧。然后他就起身走开了。噢，没错。他就在他走开的那一刻拍的。
Yes. Yes. It's pretty amazing. Angela, before we wrap up, we had a fan question from Devon Couch. Was there ever a baby poster shirt? And did Oscar ever wear it? I went through all the deleted scenes and didn't see one, but do you know? No, I don't believe there was. I don't believe it and I would have loved it. That would have been a fantastic callback years later if we had just seen him in that
没错。没错。太神奇了。安吉拉，在结束之前，我们有一个来自德文·库奇的粉丝提问。有没有过婴儿海报衬衫？奥斯卡穿过吗？我翻遍了所有删减片段，没看到过，你知道吗？不，我不认为有过。我不相信有，而且我会很喜欢那个梗。如果多年后我们能看到他穿那件衬衫一次，那将是一个非常棒的呼应，
shirt one time or maybe like when Angela had to move in with Oscar, maybe she found the shirt in his closet, something. But no, I don't have a memory of that. But that would have been fantastic. I agree. I wish that we owned the rights to that picture because I would buy that shirt. Would you buy it and wear it? Maybe.
或者比如当安吉拉不得不搬去和奥斯卡住时，也许她在他的衣柜里发现了那件衬衫，之类的。但没有，我没有那样的记忆。但这会很棒。我同意。我希望我们拥有那张照片的版权，因为我会买那件衬衫。你会买来穿吗？也许吧。
Why not? Why not? Why not? It's such like a, it would be such a fun inside joke, I think. You are wearing a hoodie right now with your own image on it, so. Office ladies? It's office ladies. I always wear my office ladies hoodie
为什么不呢？为什么不呢？为什么不呢？我觉得那会是一个非常有趣的内部笑话。你现在正穿着一件印有你自己形象的连帽衫，所以。Office Ladies？是Office Ladies。我录制Office Ladies时总是穿我的Office Ladies连帽衫，
when we record office ladies. It's like a uniform. It's my little uniform. I like a uniform. I went to a Catholic girls high school. Yes, you know. I am kidding. Of course you like the structure.
就像制服一样。这是我的小制服。我喜欢制服。我上的是天主教女子高中。没错，你知道的。我在开玩笑。你当然喜欢这种结构。
You like uniform. You like order. How about that? Yes. Order. Love order. Yeah. Feel very safe in order. There you go. Chaos. Terrifying to me. Terrifying. All right. You guys, this has been conflict resolution. We hope you enjoyed it. Thanks for listening in to us in our closets. We hope you're staying safe and we're sending you our love. We're sending you our love. Thanks guys. Next week, we are gonna be back with,
你喜欢制服。你喜欢秩序。那怎么样？没错。秩序。热爱秩序。没错。在秩序中感到非常安全。就是这样。混乱。对我来说太可怕了。太可怕了。好了。伙计们，这就是《冲突解决》。希望你们喜欢。感谢收听我们在衣柜里的录音。希望你们保持安全，我们向你们发送我们的爱。我们向你们发送我们的爱。谢谢大家。下周，我们将带着，
oh, Ange. Oh, lady. Casino night. Lady, lady, lady. And a special guest. So tune in for that. Okay. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by
噢，安吉。噢，女士。赌场之夜。女士，女士，女士。还有一位特别嘉宾。所以请收听那一集。好的。再见。再见。感谢收听Office Ladies的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。